Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Das hier ist Ausgabe 139 und heute geht es mal wieder um die Ukraine.
Ausnahmsweise mal nicht mit Pawel, sondern heute ist Enno mal wieder da. Hallo Enno.
Hallo Tim.
Ja Enno, dich hatten wir ja hier schon ein paar Mal und wie alle wissen,
bist du ja häufiger mal auf Urlaub in der Ukraine.
Andere Leute haben andere Vorstellungen von Urlaub, aber für dich ist das ja
immer ganz unterhaltsam, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, wie ein Kollege irgendwie die Tage sagt, lachen kann man nur, wenn man nicht tot ist.
Also wenn man es geschafft hat, dann ist die Geschichte lustig, ja.
Ja, genau. Und das war so ein bisschen der Anlass, dass ich dich eingeladen
habe, dass wir mal hier einen Blick direkt vor Ort bekommen.
Denn eigentlich ist jetzt seit der letzten Sendung, wie man so schön sagt, nicht viel passiert.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen zynisch formuliert, weil da passiert die ganze Zeit irgendetwas.
Es passiert nur genau das gleiche, was wir auch schon vorher berichtet haben.
Wir sind eben gerade auch nochmal die Liste durchgegangen, worüber wir so in
der letzten Sendung, also in der letzten Sendung mit Pawel, berichtet haben.
Und im Wesentlichen setzt sich das fort. Politisch keine Fortschritte,
Trump immer noch völlig delirös und nur an seinen eigenen Vorteil interessiert.
Da kommen keine Vorschläge.
Gerade heute hatten wir jetzt wieder so eine Initiative mit,
ja, heute ist es mal wieder, ja, jetzt gib doch mal Land wieder ab.
Immer hin und her, alles vollkommen egal. Ich glaube, man kann generell festhalten,
solange diese Trump-Regierung am Start ist, ist von den USA einfach überhaupt nichts zu erwarten.
Ja, ich denke immer, ich bin ja inzwischen vorsichtig, seitdem wir halt den Bush Junior hatten.
Und dann hatten wir Trump. Also ich meine, die Treppe geht immer noch abwärts, ne?
Ja, wobei in dieser ganzen Erratik, muss man vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen,
gab es ja schon eine Neuigkeit,
dass jetzt zumindest, und es ist noch ein bisschen unklar warum eigentlich,
aber sich die US-Regierung ja durchringen konnte, dann doch mal etwas weitergehende
Sanktionen zu verhängen gegen Russland, gegen Lukoil, gegen,
hier ist nochmal die andere große russische Energieunternehmen.
Also ging im Wesentlichen die Ölindustrie.
Das heißt, das waren tatsächlich, und ich würde mal sagen eher so durch Zufall,
weil ihnen vielleicht gerade nichts Besseres eingefallen ist.
Wirklich mal Sanktionen, die den Russen wehgetan haben, weil man sieht,
dass jetzt deutlich weniger exportiert wird.
Der Ölpreis sinkt trotzdem auch durch die fortgesetzten Angriffe der Ukraine
natürlich auf die Raffinerieinfrastruktur und Pipelines und jetzt auch die Ölhäfen im Schwarzen Meer.
Und sinkt also Russlands Möglichkeit einerseits Öl überhaupt aus dem Land zu
bekommen und das Öl, was sie aus dem Land noch bekommen,
weiter zu verkaufen, weil auch jetzt Indien und China ihre Bestellungen zurückgefahren
haben, weil sie eben dieses doch relativ scharfe Schwert der USA,
dieser Second Level Sanktionen befürchten,
dass also Unternehmen dann auf einmal nicht mehr so sehr mit den USA traden,
wenn ihnen halt nachgewiesen wird, dass sie auf der anderen Seite Öl aus Russland beziehen.
Also das war tatsächlich jetzt mal ein Fortschritt und man hätte fast sagen
können, jetzt kommen sie ja endlich zur Besinnung.
Aber dann kommen halt wieder so Sachen wie, ja, aber Ungarn kriegt jetzt eine Ausnahme.
Und wir, damit der BER weiter seinen Sprit bekommt.
Wie Deutschland kriegt da eine Ausnahme?
Na, diese Gazprom Deutschland, die jetzt ja Seefe GmbH oder so heißt,
also in Schwedt, die haben eine Ausnahme, die versorgen ja maßgeblich den BER auch.
Aber die sind doch schon beschlagnahmt worden.
Ja, genau, das ist aber der Punkt. Die sind sozusagen temporär unter deutscher
Verwaltung, aber die Gewinne werden gesammelt und theoretisch geht das,
glaube ich, ein, zwei Jahre.
Und wenn es nicht verlängert wird, geht es dann zurück.
Also das ist der eine Punkt. Also es ist nicht final.
Das andere ist ja, das ist ja aber das kasachische Öl, was zwar durch Russland
in der gleichen Pipeline läuft, aber eine Nicht-Vermischt-Garantie von Russland
hat, dass es sich garantiert nicht in der gleichen Pipeline mit russischem Öl mischt.
Was ich auch so ein bisschen ... Naja, und im Normalfall macht man dann ja so
eine Art Importkontrolle, weil das Öl ja am Ende unterschiedlich ist.
Es wird nur bei dieser Pipeline explizit nicht gemacht, Weil wir ja so sicher
sind, dass wir es nicht mal kontrollieren müssen.
Weil ja Russland so ein stabiler und zuverlässiger Partner ist in allen Dingen.
Genau. Also wenn man das Ding in Schwedt wenigstens eingeheimst hätte und jetzt
sagen würde, es ist unsers und kein russisches Öl, okay.
Aber es ist halt so ein Wackeldackel am Ende, dass es theoretisch am Ende wieder zurückgeht.
Und da muss man sehen, wie das genau sich entwickelt.
Und an der Stelle merkt man auch gleich mal wieder das perfide des Systems Trump,
weil da ja quasi die Russen jetzt durch diese Sanktionen mehr oder weniger dazu gezwungen werden,
ihre im russischen Besitz befindlichen Energiestandorte zu verkaufen.
Also das betrifft, glaube ich, so Installationen in Moldawien und ich meine
auch in der Schweiz und dann gab es jetzt theoretisch eigentlich so eine Frist von einem Monat,
bis wann das abgestoßen sein muss,
damit die Russen da quasi überhaupt noch irgendwas von haben.
Da gab es dann zum Beispiel in der Schweiz auch ein Schweizer Unternehmen,
was das dann irgendwie übernommen hätte.
Und da hat dann aber Russland gesagt, wenn ihr das kauft, dann sanktionieren wir euch trotzdem.
Aber rein zufällig haben wir hier in den USA jemanden, der es gerne kaufen würde.
Mit anderen Worten, die Amerikaner versuchen jetzt sozusagen die Russen über
diese Sanktionen dazu zu zwingen, ihre Assets zu verkaufen, aber wollen dann
sozusagen das dann auch gleich alles wieder in die USA holen,
um dann quasi die Energiehoheit in all diesen Ländern dann bei ihnen liegen zu haben.
Also sozusagen den einen Bulli gegen den anderen Bulli austauschen,
man kann einfach nur noch mit dem Kopf schütteln, du machst das gerade.
Es ist ja wie, wenn man sagen würde, Griechenland, ihr müsst eure Assets verkaufen,
aber deutsche Unternehmen hätten da gerade noch Geld über.
Genau, nicht viel, aber ja.
Ich meine, am Ende macht es jeder. Nur die einen sind die Guten,
die es machen und die anderen sind die Bösen, die es machen.
Aber ja, auffällig, wie immer genau die richtigen US-Unternehmen gerade Kaufbedarf haben.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall alles...
Das ist hochgradig korrupt auf allen Seiten und umso mehr kann man sich eigentlich
nur darüber wundern, dass es den Europäern da nicht gelingt,
eine einheitliche Front gegenüber diesem ganzen Unsinn zu finden.
Was natürlich viel damit zu tun hat, dass nach
wie vor die USA auch gegenüber Europa ein großes Drohpotenzial haben mit ihren
Zöllen und was sie sonst eben noch alles so liefern und da wir uns ja jetzt
auch in der Gasversorgung teilweise dann eben auch auf die USA als Förderland eingelassen haben,
zieht das natürlich an der Stelle auch.
Nach dem Motto so, ah, okay, ihr wollt ja kein russisches Gas mehr.
Dann hängt er jetzt also bei uns am Tropf, dann haben wir da ja auch wieder einen Hebel.
Ich meine, was ich in gewisser Hinsicht ganz interessant finde,
ich hätte es fast lustig gesagt, lustig ist es nicht wirklich, aber...
Nie war, glaube ich, so diese internationale Machtpolitik so sichtbar und wo
sie normalerweise so hinter den Kulissen und hinter schönen Worten stattfindet.
Und das ist ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Trump ist da einfach Trampel genug.
Um… Aber genau das finde ich eigentlich ganz interessant an Trump,
dass man ja sagen kann, hey, zumindest ist es plakativ und da.
Also das finde ich ja eine Nummer einfacher, als wenn man lange bohren muss.
Also er macht es einem ja schon ein bisschen komfortabler, die ganze Nummer.
Das Ergebnis ist das gleiche. Aber halt auch der Punkt, die EU,
also jetzt mal grob von Fläche, Wirtschaftsleistung, Bevölkerung,
halbwegs vergleichbar mit den USA.
Und was mich immer aufregt, nicht einfach nur, was die USA treiben,
sondern dass man sagt, warum ist das denn so wichtig für uns?
Warum sind wir denn nicht der, der die USA an den Eiern hat?
Also per se stehen wir da ja auf Augenhöhe, aber praktisch ist es irgendwie
gar nicht so. Und das ärgert mich halt.
Und dann heißt ja, keine Ahnung, das liegt daran, dass wir hier so viele Länder
haben oder dies, das, wo ich denke, nee, nee, niemand hindert viele Leute daran,
zusammen was zu machen. Also außer die Leute sich selber.
Und das ist, was mich halt daran so aufregt. Und irgendwie nicht eine Regierung
hat hier richtig Rückgrat oder nicht eine große, wichtige.
Also die baltischen Staaten sind immer super dabei, aber die sind halt nicht stark genug.
Aber sowas würde ich mir ja wünschen. Ich dachte auch bei der letzten Bundestagswahl,
ich habe von so vielen Leuten wie noch nie gehört, ich weiß nicht,
wen ich wählen soll, also Leute,
die wählen wollen, die auch mal ihre Lieblingspartei oder so hatten.
Und die dann sagten, quer durch die Reihe, also die FDP-Wähler,
die gesagt haben, ich wurde von der Ampel enttäuscht, die Grünen-Wähler,
die gesagt haben, ich wurde von der Ampel enttäuscht, die SPD-Wähler,
wo ich dachte, hey geil, drei von drei waren nicht zufrieden.
Das ist auch schon rekordverdächtig.
Okay, AfD eh nicht, Linke sozusagen
den sozialen Teil ja, den Ex-Sowjet-Freunde-Teil nicht und so. Und.
Dann von ein paar habe ich gehört, dass sie so nach Ausschlussverfahren bei
der CDU landen, aber nicht mit Freude,
sondern sozusagen der Letzte, der steht, wenn du die anderen umgekippt hast
und sagen, okay und nicht mal die machen mehr Law and Order oder sowas,
also nicht mehr mal darauf kannst du dich verlassen, dass die jetzt irgendwie
weder die Wirtschaft noch zeigen sie es den Amis.
Also niemand ist mehr mit irgendwas richtig zufrieden und das finde ich halt
auch so schlimm, weil dass man die Diskussion früher mit Nichtwählern oder mit
ungebildeten, so politisch ungebildeten Leuten hatte, klar, passiert.
Aber dass es jetzt so in meinem Freundeskreis Leute sind, die sich mit befassen
und die einfach keine Partei mehr haben, wo sie sagen und dieses voll und das
finde ich super, das finde ich halt so sehr traurig für eine Demokratie.
Also wir haben viele Parteien Auswahl und dass ich so viel höre,
dass keiner mehr richtig passt, das ist dann halt einfach schlecht fürs gesamte System irgendwann.
Ja, also ich will jetzt nicht so sehr auf deutsche Innenpolitik eingehen, das ist traurig genug.
Mich interessiert halt dann vor allem eben, was bewirkt Europa im Konzert.
Ich meine, wenn wir das mal kurz noch aufgreifen, was die CDU jetzt da geleistet hat.
Ich meine, zumindest ist dieser totale Eierkurs von Scholz erstmal weg.
Und einige Dinge sind klarer geworden.
Es gibt dann sehr viel klarere Unterstützung, was so Waffenlieferungen und so
weiter und was man damit auch machen darf. Das hat sich schon verbessert.
Und wir haben wie versprochen Taurus geliefert?
Haben wir.
Nein, haben wir nicht. Das war nur ein Wahlversprechen.
Naja, ich denke, also das ist jetzt nur so ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen gelesen, aber ...
Es hat, glaube ich, schon einen Technologietransfer gegeben.
Ja, definitiv.
Und das mag dann zu anderen Systemen kontributiert haben.
Darüber weiß ich jetzt nichts Konkretes, aber da ja jetzt sozusagen diese Flamingo-Missiles
und so weiter in zunehmendem Maße auch besser treffen und lange Strecken fliegen,
ist, glaube ich, dieser Taurus-Bedarf gar nicht mehr so akut.
Und man hat das irgendwie anders gelöst.
Ich meine, Taurus war ja auch ein Punkt für die Kerchbrücke.
Aber dass die so ein Dreh- und Angelpunkt ist, ist jetzt auch zwei, drei Jahre her.
Also zumindest was das angeht, hat sich ja auch einfach, also ist nicht mehr
relevant, seitdem die parallele Bahnstrecke läuft oder bei Weib nicht mehr so relevant.
Und ja, beim Flamingo gab es wohl so einen plötzlichen Moment,
in dem das Radar gut besser wurde vor wenigen Monaten und seitdem ist die im
Einsatz. Also so habe ich es gehört.
Und die Geschichte ist halt, dass einfach ein ukrainischer Mitarbeiter morgens
aufwachte und die Idee hatte.
So ganz zufällig.
Was durchaus sein kann. Wer jetzt unseren Sendungen vielleicht nicht ganz so
regelmäßig folgt, sollten wir die Begrifflichkeiten vielleicht auch nochmal
ein bisschen unterfüttern.
Also Flamingo ist der Name der neuen, relativ neuen Long Range Missile von,
also keine ballistische, sondern so ein Cruise Missile von den Ukrainern,
von denen sie jetzt auch gleich zu Beginn behauptet haben, dass sie auf so eine
Tagesproduktion von sieben kommen wollen.
Was schon ein beträchtliches Arsenal wäre, wenn denn auch die ganzen anderen
Daten stimmen, wie eine Range von 3000 Kilometern, was wirklich, wirklich viel ist,
ein Warhead, also ein Sprengkopf von bis zu einer Tonne, glaube ich.
Das ist viel.
Das ist schon alles sehr viel. Also so auf dem Papier ist das sozusagen alles
mehr als jetzt so eine amerikanische Tomahawk, die zwar sehr alt ist,
aber immer noch so das Rückgrat der amerikanischen Angriffsszenarien ist,
so wie wir das jetzt auch im Irak gesehen haben, abgesehen von diesen Bunkerbomben,
die ja noch zum Einsatz kamen.
Sogar mehrmals im Irak, also quasi in jedem Irakkrieg. Das Ding ist ja älter.
Habt ihr Irak oder Iran gesagt?
Iran. Ich meinte Iran. Aber ich wollte sagen, Iran und Irak ist das Ding ja
in vier oder fünf Kriegen im Einsatz gewesen.
Also es ist ein Dauerbrenner und es ist natürlich insofern auch abgehangene
Technologie und wird halt normalerweise auch von U-Booten gelauncht, dann gebraucht.
Gab es ja dann auch wieder so eine windige Diskussion, ob denn die USA vielleicht
auch Tomahawks bereitstellen.
Aber das sind glaube ich immer alles nur so Nebelkerzen, die die Trump-Regierung
zündet, um alle irgendwie weiterhin in so permanenter Unsicherheit zu wägen.
Was ja auch ganz gut gelingt.
Und ich glaube bei Trump auch einfach, dass er wieder eine Headline hat.
Also auch ist ja nicht nur politisch, sondern auch sehr persönlich da.
Ja genau. Ja okay, also das ist diese Flamingo-Missile.
Auf andere Technologien kommen wir vielleicht. Das muss man ein bisschen hier
wieder zusammenrollen.
Also im Großen und Ganzen, diese Sanktionen haben tatsächlich etwas bewirkt,
werden trotzdem von den USA genutzt für ihre persönliche Bereicherung der Cronies von Trump.
Nichtsdestotrotz hat das die Situation für die Ukraine an sich verbessert,
aber jetzt rein politisch, was mögliche Verhandlungen oder größeren Druck auf Russland betrifft,
ist es halt alles nach wie vor totales Larifari.
Und man kann sagen, das würde mich auch mal interessieren, wie du das jetzt
wahrgenommen hast, weil das war so ein bisschen, was ich so das Gefühl hatte,
dass die Ukraine vermutlich schon seit längerem,
aber jetzt auch in zunehmendem Maße die Politik verfolgt mit Deutschland.
Von außen wird keine entscheidende Hilfe kommen. Es gibt für uns eigentlich
nur den Weg, selber stärker zu sein als die Russen.
Sollte sich an dieser Situation was ändern, okay, nehmen wir.
Aber es ist nichts, auf das wir strategisch setzen.
Mit anderen Worten, unsere Strategie ist, wir entwickeln alle unsere Waffen,
wir bauen sie primär im eigenen Land.
Wir bauen sie so gut, dass wir Interesse erhalten von anderen Ländern und bauen
uns parallel damit noch eine Exportindustrie auf, die dazu führen kann, dass wir dann,
wie das eben mit jeder guten Waffenexportindustrie ist,
diesen inneren Bedarf auch mitfinanziert.
Und wir spielen Trumps Lied und welchen Anzug jetzt Selinski tragen soll,
das machen wir alles mit.
Wir fahren da auch überall hin, wir sind immer da, aber unsere Erwartungen an
den Westen, vor allem an die USA, ist null und unsere Erwartungen an Europa,
hängt sehr von dem einzelnen Land ab, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, also aus meiner Sicht kommt das absolut hin. Man muss ja auch immer bedenken,
die Ukraine hatte eine sehr starke Rüstungsindustrie, also nicht moderne Rüstung,
nicht jetzt wie das, was wir so aus,
Lockheed-Martin oder so einer F-35 gewohnt sind, aber die hatten...
Die waren relativ stark im Bau von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen,
also einfache abgehangene Technik, aber ich glaube aus westlicher Sicht meint
man immer, dass diese Hightech-Sachen so wichtig sind und der Großteil vom Waffenmarkt
sind immer noch alte Panzer, Kalaschnikows und einfache Sachen.
Also das ist, wo die Menge an Aufträgen liegt.
Und auch was Raumfahrt angeht, also Raumfahrt und Rüstungstechnik liegt dann
ja oft dicht beieinander.
Die Ukrainer haben ja massiv die Hardware gebaut für sowjetische Raumfahrtprogramme
und vor allem Triebwerke, Steuertechnik, auch von den Atombomben und so weiter. haben.
Das heißt, dieses ganze Wissen, was da liegt, deswegen wundert es mich auch
nicht, wenn sie jetzt eine Flamingo bauen, also selbst wenn die,
öffentlichen Werte doppelt übertrieben sind oder so, wenn das Ding 1500 Kilometer
fliegt mit 500 Kilo, dann wäre das immer noch ein ordentliches Teil und das
glaubt man denen halt, weil man weiß, die bauen das.
Die haben ja auch die beiden Flugzeugträger im Prinzip der Sowjetunion gebaut,
also der eine, der dann immer noch so halb abgesoffen bis heute durch die Gegend
tümpelt und Und der andere ist wahrscheinlich eine eigene Sendung wert.
Den hat so ein verrückter Milliardär aus Makao gekauft, um ein Casino draus zu machen.
Und dann kam raus, dass das nur eine Deckfirma von der chinesischen Regierung
war. Und dann haben sie das als Vorlage für ihren Flugzeugträger.
Also so eine typische Geschichte im Prinzip, wo aber so alles bei ist.
Aber man sagt, die wissen, wie es geht. Also die haben eine Menge Wissen, die waren dran.
Und deswegen, ja, ich denke, die haben sich am Anfang mehr Hilfe erhofft.
Und jetzt bauen sie halt wieder selber und bauen auf.
Und das, also, ich glaube, der Punkt ist immer, es dauert ja so,
bis man Schwung holt und dann zieht man an allen vorbei. Und ich denke,
dass wir das in der Ukraine jetzt gerade sehen.
Also mit der Flamingo sind wir jetzt ja auf dem Punkt, wo sie so ein konkurrenzfähiges
Ding haben, was sie auf dem Weltmarkt verkaufen könnten, wenn das wirklich das
bringt, was wir jetzt sehen.
Dann wäre das ein normales System, was man gut an den Mann kriegt.
Und das haben sie jetzt aber in den letzten Jahren hochgefahren.
Das heißt, wo sind wir da in zwei, drei Jahren, wenn die weiter so Gas geben
und ja auch diesen Leistungsdruck haben, was zu bringen?
Da denke ich, dass die da noch eine ganze Menge an Sachen rausholen werden und
eben diese ganze Drohnentechnologie, also Drohnengem doch noch detektieren.
Also dieses Katz-und-Maus-Spiel haben die jetzt auch quasi drei Runden durchgespielt.
Deswegen denke ich, wenn der Krieg mal vorbei ist, die werden in allen Militäruniversitäten
der Welt Vorträge halten und ihre Systeme exportieren.
Und ja, die setzen jetzt halt drauf, dass sie sich selber durchbeißen,
weil anders wird es nichts.
Ja, diese Interceptor-Drohnen scheinen ja auch auf besonderes Interesse gestoßen zu sein.
Spätestens nachdem offenbar die Russen auch europäische Flughäfen jetzt mit
irgendwelchen UFOs beglückt.
Um...
Teilweise sollen die ja auch im Ausland gebaut werden. Ich glaube Dänemark und
auch die Franzosen und die Deutschen auch.
Ja, hier gibt es auch. Also nicht das End-Assembly oder wie das heißt,
aber hier werden Teile davon genau Komponenten gemacht.
Und das macht ja auch total Sinn, also die Produktionsorte der anderen Länder
zu nutzen und daraus dann auch noch gleich so einen Deal zu machen mit,
ja, könnt ihr auch gebrauchen.
Weil ich glaube, das könnte sich am Ende fast als eine der wirkungsvollsten
Verteidigungssysteme herausstellen, wenn die noch weiter verbessert werden.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, woran es jetzt hakt, ob es eine Frage der Anzahl
ist oder ob die bestimmte Missiles noch nicht eingeholt bekommen.
Gerade so ballistische Raketen wäre ja interessant, wenn man die sozusagen auch
runterholen kann, weil die derzeit noch das größte Problem darstellen,
so Kinsal und ähnliche Systeme.
Ja, in dem Zuge, dann haben wir das auch gut abgearbeitet,
eine weitere interessante Meldung war, und es waren dann im Prinzip gleich zwei
Meldungen hintereinander, dass sich die Ukraine offenbar mit Schweden geeinigt
hat auf die Lieferung von den Gripenfighters.
Das hatten wir hier in der Sendung auch schon mal thematisiert,
als die Diskussion das erste Mal aufkam und die kam schon vor einiger Zeit auf,
das ist schon über ein Jahr her.
Die Gripenflugzeuge sind für die Ukraine, glaube ich, aus mehreren Gründen interessant.
Also erstmal ist natürlich Schweden, denke ich mal, auch einer der verlässlichsten
Partner für die Ukraine, weil da gibt es jetzt irgendwie keine Befürchtung einer
Trampisierung, also zumindest bisher nicht.
Dann sind die Schweden ja auch schon immer sehr pfiffig gewesen was Waffentechnik
betrifft und die Gripen haben halt also Gripen ist entwickelt worden auf Basis des Bedarfs Schwedens,
der sich mit dem Bedarf der Ukraine auf interessante Weise sehr gut deckt,
weil das eben so ein Flugzeug ist, was vor allem darauf ausgelegt ist,
so Low Maintenance und Low Cost zu sein.
Das heißt, die Betriebsstunden sind sehr viel günstiger, als das jetzt bei so einer F-16 ist.
Man braucht nicht so große Teams und die Wartung ist so optimiert,
dass man das Ding im Prinzip auf jeder Wiese landen lassen kann und mit einem
Truck kommt man dann vorbei.
Also speziell war es darauf optimiert, auf einer Autobahn zu landen und auf
der Raststätte zu warten, was halt tatsächlich genau der Use Case war.
Das heißt, wer eine Autobahn und eine Raststätte hat, kann loslegen.
Genau, man braucht also keine dedizierten, voll ausgebauten,
mit Hightech vollgestopften Flughäfen dafür und Servicezentren,
sondern man kann das eben sehr gut verteilen und das ist natürlich einerseits
für die Ukraine interessant,
weil sie eben diese Orte nicht haben und andererseits diese Orte natürlich dann
auch unter extremer Angriffsgefahr sind und dann extrem gesichert werden müssten.
Aber wenn man das dann eben überall machen kann, dann ist gut.
Und vor allem war die Menge an Flugzeugen, die zugesagt wurde oder von der jetzt
die Rede ist, war extrem hoch.
Also von 100 bis zu 150 Flugzeugen.
Das ist, ich erinnere mich noch, als wir die ganze F-16 Diskussion hatten,
gab es ja schon diese Einschätzung, wenn wir davon 150 hätten,
damit könnten wir den Luftraum der Ukraine sichern.
Ob das jetzt stimmt oder ob das damals nur eine politisch angemessene Zahl war,
weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Aber das geht schon so in diese Richtung.
Und ein paar Tage später meldete sich dann auch noch Frankreich zu Wort und
hat Rafale-Flugzeuge zugesagt, auch in dieser ähnlichen Größenordnung von dreistellig.
Und sowohl im Falle der Gripen als auch im Falle der Rafale handelt es sich
jetzt hierbei nicht um alte, ausgemusterte, steht hier noch rum,
könnt ihr haben Flugzeuge, sondern jeweils sind hier gemeint die neueste Version.
Also bei der Rafale F4 oder so und bei der Gripen auch die neueste Variante,
ich glaube es ist auch eine 4 drin.
Also jeweils sozusagen die aktuelle Geschichte, was insofern sehr wichtig ist,
weil das meistens bei diesen Flugzeugen bedeutet,
dass sie dann die modernsten Radarsysteme an Bord haben, die also weitreichend
und feinfühlig sind, was halt sehr wichtig ist, um möglichst weit weg von einer
Kontaktlinie schon Gegner aufspüren zu können.
Also Angriffe oder eben auch Flugzeuge, die man vielleicht selber abschießen möchte.
Und es bedeutet, dass auch diese Flugzeuge in der Regel, und ich gehe mal davon
aus, das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, aber ich gehe einfach mal davon aus,
dass die sozusagen alle Adaptoren und alle Software haben, um sozusagen die
komplette moderne NATO-Waffentechnik an Raketen, Sightwinder und was weiß ich,
auch an diese Maschinen randocken zu können und damit fliegen zu können.
Ja und die hochauflösenden Radare sind halt wichtig, vor allem für die Scharhead-Drohnen und sowas.
Also eigentlich will man mit dem Kampfjet keine Scharhead abschießen,
weil das Kostenverhältnis nicht stimmt. Aber am Ende schießt man halt mit dem, was man hat.
Billiger ist halt vom Hubschrauber aus mit dem Bordgeschütz,
was ja derzeit auch so die Top-Lösung der Ukrainer ist.
Also was die höchste Killrate bei den Scharheads hat und was billig ist.
Also weil man im Prinzip einen alten Heli hat, wo man nur die Betriebskosten
hat, die sind überschaubar.
Die sind da so, ich glaube, so 2.000, 3.000 Dollar pro Stunde ungefähr.
Also je nachdem, wie man den fliegt. Aber das ist verglichen mit einem Kampfjet nichts.
Und sie haben viele. Und selbst ein Hubschrauber, der kein Geschütz hat,
kann man im Prinzip in die Tür so ein russisches Duschcar hängen.
Und da muss man ein bisschen üben. Und dann geht das. Also das ist so die Low-Cost-Lösung,
um Schahed sehr gut runterzuschießen.
Und die Schahed und der Hubschrauber können ähnlich schnell fliegen.
Ein Kampfjet ist ja meist schneller. Und dann hat man so verschiedene Probleme.
Aber wir bringen ja immer wieder auch Sachen aus der Ukraine mit,
unter anderem Schahed, Rumpfteile und so.
Und da ist uns auch aufgefallen, dass die im letzten Jahr die Materialien ein
bisschen verändert haben.
Nicht groß, aber Stück für Stück, sodass am Ende die Rückstrahlfläche,
also was man auf dem Radar sieht von so einer Schalt, in einem Jahr um 20 bis
30 Prozent gesunken ist.
Und das macht halt schon einen Unterschied.
Also sieht man halt später, da sieht man schlechter, da sieht man gar nicht.
Und deswegen ist es halt auch wichtig, dass die bessere Radare haben,
und die ansonsten, was sie halt viel machen, ist eben mit Thermalsichtgeräten,
also mit sehr, sehr guten, mit hochauflösenden Arbeiten, weil man damit die
Scharhead-Motoren immer gut sieht
und das ist, was diese Teams am Boden machen, die nach oben schießen.
Die haben einfach meist eine Thermalkamera und nachdem das aber zu gut ging,
haben sie die Scharheads höher fliegen lassen.
Die fliegen jetzt meist auf vier bis fünf Kilometer Höhe an und dann braucht
man halt wieder Hubschrauber oder Jet.
Aber deswegen also die neuen Jets mit einer hohen Auflösung,
die können dann zumindest helfen, die zu erfassen, in der Hoffnung,
dass sie dann aber jemand anders abschießt.
Und da muss es jeder eben kompatibel, vernetzt und so weiter sein.
Ja, also das ist sozusagen die Situation.
Man sieht hier, dass wie in vielen anderen Bereichen des Krieges auch eine unglaubliche
Geschwindigkeit in der jeweiligen Aufrüstung beider Seiten ist.
Also sowohl was die Technik betrifft, als auch was die Strategien betrifft,
die gefahren werden und auch wenn man den Russen immer mal wieder Beklopptheit nachweisen kann,
gilt das halt mitnichten für die gesamte Armee.
Da sind dann doch schon leider immer wieder noch ein paar kluge Köpfe dabei,
die ihr Handwerk verstehen und dementsprechend ist es so ein permanentes Wettrüsten
und hat eben viel mit so einer Reaktionsgeschwindigkeit zu tun,
die glaube ich der Westen noch nicht so richtig mitlebt.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob sich bei der Bundeswehr da mittlerweile was verbessert hat, aber Zweifel.
Auch ein bisschen sowohl mit Russland im Krieg und Trump in der Politik finde
ich so, was man bei beiden sieht ist, wie aufgeschmissen die westliche Welt
ist, wenn einer nicht mitspielt oder nicht nach den üblichen Regeln spielt.
Also wie Trump, der Mahü Mahot sagt und sagt, wir zuerst.
Und auf einmal weiß die ganze Weltgemeinschaft nicht mehr so richtig, was sie tun soll.
Und auch mit Putin, wenn ich dann immer wieder sage, warum lassen wir denn die
Kriegsschiffe vor unserer Küste langfahren?
Dann heißt es ja, weil wir einen Vertrag mit denen unterschrieben haben.
Das ist heute noch eure Begründung von Regierungsseite.
Ja, aber das steht ja auf dem Papier.
Man sagt, okay, da kollidieren so zwei Welten, die einfach nicht kompatibel sind.
Tja, law based also wir haben uns dran gewöhnt dass man alles vertraglich regeln
kann, aber wenn jemand sich an diese Verträge schlicht nicht hält dann wissen
wir auch nicht so richtig was zu tun ist,
ja, lass mal auf deine Reise jetzt zurückkommen,
Wo hat es sich denn dieses Mal zuerst hingeführt?
Zuerst nach Kiew, weil von da kommt man ja überall hin.
Und als ich ankam in Kiew, war es auch relativ harmlos.
Also keine großen Angriffe an dem Tag, also gar keine an dem Tag.
Und die einzigen Probleme, die man doch deutlich merkt, auch mehr als in den
letzten Jahren, sind die Angriffe auf die Infrastruktur, also vor allem Heizung und Strom.
Das ist, also es war mal besser, mal schlechter. Und zur Zeit ist es wirklich,
wirklich schlecht. Also das kann man schon sagen, das geht deutlich runter.
Vor allem, weil es kalt wird. Also ganz praktisch kann man sagen,
ohne Strom kann man so als durchschnittlicher Nerd eine ganze Weile auskommen,
weil das Handy hat Akku, der Laptop hat Akku.
Und wenn man das alle paar Stunden lädt, dann kommt man ja so über den Tag.
Und die Cafés, die größeren, haben meist Generatoren, also oft wirklich große
irgendwo im Hof, nicht so einen kleinen Seilstarter davor, sodass die einfach
durchlaufen und WiFi und alles haben. Also das geht.
Nur wenn man dann nach Hause kommt, also ein Handynetz, mobiles Internet, das läuft alles.
Und wenn man dann aber nach Hause kommt und der gesamte Wohnblock ist kalt seit
einem Tag, also so nicht wie in Berlin, man ist gewohnt, man hat die Heizung
ausgelassen, aber alle drumherum hatten geheizt. Und in zehn Minuten wird es
wärmer, sondern so richtig ausgekühlt.
Also wie wenn man in so eine Geisterstadt kommt.
Das hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet, was das für ein Problem ist,
weil man es einfach gar nicht mehr gewohnt ist, selbst in der Ukraine nicht.
Das Gute in unserem Fall war, dass Gas noch funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Und weil wir in dem Apartment ein Gasherd haben, haben wir dann halt die Küchentür
zugemacht und Gasflammen an.
Und das heizt halt relativ gut, also so offenes Feuer und dann eben mobiles
Internet und dann kann man arbeiten und das geht so.
Aber da merkt man so, wie es halt nicht mehr der übliche Zivilisationsstandard ist.
Das komische ist halt dieser Bruch, also wenn wir dann zu viel hatten,
haben wir gesagt, lass rüber gehen ins Fünf-Sterne-Hotel gegenüber,
dann sitzt man dann in der warmen Lobby und haben Avocado-Tempura gegessen und
irgendwelche Eclairs und frisch gemahlenen Kaffee und dann gehst du halt auf
die andere Straßenseite wieder in dein Apartment, wo du mit dem Ofen heizt.
Also sowas ist schon, es ist sehr dicht beisammen.
Ja, als wir vor zwei Jahren gemeinsam in den Kief waren, war davon nichts zu sehen.
Strom war immer da, alles war eigentlich vollkommen normal und es gab einfach
nur diesen Unterschied, so Front alles scheiße, Hinterland alles super.
Aber jetzt sind die Russen einfach sehr erfolgreich leider da drin,
primär wahrscheinlich durch diese ballistischen Raketen, aber eben teilweise
auch durch die Schahets gezielt die ganze Kraftwerksinfrastruktur anzugreifen.
Ich höre immer sehr unterschiedliche Aussagen darüber, wie viel Prozent jetzt
wirklich gerade dysfunktional ist, aber Stromausfälle sind halt normal,
beziehungsweise es gibt ohnehin schon so vorab glaube ich auch so Pläne,
wann gibt es Strom und so.
Genau so zwei, drei Tage vorher kriegt
man die immer, aber die normalen Telegram-Channel. Ist auch ganz spannend.
Da stand dann zum Beispiel, bist du in diesem oder jenem Abschnitt in Kiew?
Und dachte, keine Ahnung. Ich dachte, das ist wie Wien, wo die Bezirke Nummern haben.
Also habe ich halt irgendwie den KI-Bot gefragt, ey, in welchem Abschnitt bin ich hier?
Und der sagt, nee, nee, nee, da geht es nicht. Das sind nicht Stadtteile.
Das ist sinngemäß, wo das Stromkabel langläuft, welches abgeschaltet wird.
Und dafür gibt es noch keine Karte, weil das bisher nie jemanden interessiert hat.
Aber auf der Homepage vom Stromversorger gibst du deine Adresse an.
Und so ein bisschen wie so eine DSL-Abfrage. Bist du rechts oder links auf der
Straße und hast du eine gerade oder eine ungerade Hausnummer,
Also man merkt, das ist schon sehr präzise.
Dann kam raus, wir sind in dem und dem Abschnitt.
Und dann kann man halt immer auf diese Tabellen, die mal so zwei,
drei Tage im Voraus kommen, gucken.
Und im Normalfall ist es so, dass man ungefähr den halben Tag vom Tag Strom
hat, aber nicht durchgehend, sondern immer so zwei bis drei Stunden blöcken.
Und deswegen geht es eigentlich, weil man so alle paar Stunden wieder ein paar Stunden Strom hat.
Und die Lösung ist halt, man holt sich eine kleine Powerstation,
packt den DSL-Router daran, weil die haben alle Glasfaser, die Vermittlungsstationen funktionieren.
Das heißt, man braucht nur Strom an seinem Router und für seinen Laptop und
dann hat man auch weiter Internet und eine kleine Lampe, die läuft und dann
lädt die Powerstation halt, wenn Strom da ist und sonst gibt es ab.
Also damit kommt man schon über die Runden.
Aber ja, das sind auch alles so Dinge, wo ich gemerkt habe, hey,
so knapp vier Jahre bin ich da jetzt in dem Krieg immer gewesen,
aber diese Frage hatte ich nie.
Also irgendwas ist jetzt anders offensichtlich. Also dass die Stromausfälle
so viel sind, dass ich mich mit befassen muss auf einmal und nicht,
dass ich sage, ja, ist ja ab und zu Strom da.
Und auch so ganz, ganz simple Dinge wie der Aufzug fährt halt nicht und im Treppenhaus
ist aber auch kein Licht.
Also dass man dran denken muss, dass man also wenigstens das Handylicht hat,
aber die meisten haben halt irgendeine kleine Taschenlampe bei,
dass man schon so ein bisschen...
Mehr Lichtschein hat. Und dann aber auch das Problem, die Wasserqualität.
Also zum einen, das Wasser kommt nicht immer bis in die oberen Etagen,
weil die Wasserpumpen nicht laufen. Also je nachdem, wie der Wasserdruck ist,
kann man Glück oder Pech haben.
Aber die sagen auch, wir sollen kein Wasser mehr trinken aus dem Hahn,
einfach weil die Klärwerke nicht mehr auf 100 Prozent laufen.
Also die sagen zum Duschen und so, alles okay, aber trinken lieber nicht,
weil die Qualität schwankt. Und das heißt, so eine durchschnittliche Familie
läuft dann immer mit so fünf bis zehn Liter Wasserkanistern irgendwie nach Hause.
Dann fährt aber der Aufzug nicht und die Hochhäuser haben da bis 40 Etagen.
Und dann sozusagen hast du diese Summe aus kleinen Problemen und da musst du
halt alle paar Tage 20 Kilo Wasser 40 Etagen hochschleppen.
Und dann wird es zu einem richtig doofen Problem halt.
Und das ist auch nicht nur in Kiew so, sondern das betrifft mittlerweile eigentlich weite Teile.
Ich glaube, dass mehr oder minder das ganze Land, also zumindest kann sein,
dass Lviv ein bisschen besser ist, weil die noch aus dem Westen Strom kriegen, aber ich meine,
es ist überall und also sozusagen als Endnutzer hat man halt nur noch so 50
Prozent Strom oder so, weil natürlich für Flugabwehr, für Industrie und so Strom reserviert ist.
Genau und deswegen ist mir auch ein bisschen unklar, wie viel wirklich geht oder nicht geht.
Und es gibt so Sachen, wir haben zum Beispiel manchmal eine Meldung bekommen, die kamen dann abends.
So Achtung, morgen ist von 8 bis 15 Uhr gar kein Strom da.
Also wahrscheinlich, weil irgendwas getroffen wurde, weil sie umverteilen mussten.
Also kurzfristig gibt es dann immer wieder so Sondermeldungen.
Ich denke, deswegen kriegt man auch immer nur so zwei, drei Tage vorher den
Plan, weil die wissen, selbst das ist schon schwierig, das überhaupt so weit zu planen.
Das Gute ist aber eigentlich, dass die Tankstellen ohne Probleme laufen.
Das heißt, die Öl- oder die Benzinversorgung funktioniert und dadurch hat man Unmengen Generatoren.
Teilweise, also Großhotels, große Restaurants haben dann schon vor Jahren so
große schallgedämpfte Dieseldinger gekauft, die man kaum mitbekommt.
Aber gerade die kleinen Cafés und Büros haben alle wie so einen Rasenmähermotor
vor der Tür. und dann läuft man halt durch Kiew und alles brummt so von diesen Dingern.
Tankstellen werden ja jetzt von den Russen auch angegriffen in letzter Zeit.
Ich war bei der einen, die jetzt vor ein paar Tagen berühmt wurde,
in Rakiv, eine VOX-Station.
Da ist eine Gleitbombe reingeschlagen und ich glaube am 9.11.,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, und hat quasi die halbe Tankstelle,
also das Gebäude weggerissen.
Und du kennst das ja, die Tankstellen da sind immer groß, noch mit dem Café,
ist fast wie ein Restaurant so groß und allem möglichen dran.
Kostenlosen Toiletten.
Ja, saubere, kostenlose Toiletten.
Nicht so wie in Deutschland.
Die man als Nichtkunde nutzen kann, ohne dass jemand ein Problem mit hat.
So und dann ist die halt von einer Gleitbombe getroffen worden.
Das halbe Gebäude ist weggeflogen.
Das ganze Gelände war verwüstet und 24 spät haben sie wieder aufgemacht und
sich für die Unannehmlichkeiten entschuldigt.
Und wir kamen da halt vorbei, deswegen wollte ich gucken.
Und das Ding ist immer noch, hinten fehlt einfach das halbe Gebäude.
Und da sind so Pylone, so diese irgendwie weiß-roten. und die stehen da so mit
Achtung, hier fehlt das Haus, aber fahr vorn rum.
Und die haben einfach zwei so Anhänger davor gestellt, ähm,
Und das Lustige ist aber, das ist nicht einfach ein Kassenanhänger,
sondern du kriegst weiter Hotdogs, Pizza, Burger, warmen Kaffee, Souvenirs, alles.
Also sie haben das volle Programm nur aus dem Anhänger und sagen,
sorry, das hat zwei Tage gedauert, bis wir die Pizza wieder backen konnten im
Hänger, aber geht weiter.
Also das finde ich einfach auch so irre, wie du halt keine zwei Tage Disruption
irgendwie hast, nachdem die Tankstelle explodiert ist.
Und das ist so das, was ich da halt an allen Ecken und Enden sehe,
wie die einfach weitermachen. Das ist unglaublich.
Und an dieser Tankstelle war es dann auch so, dass quasi alle Leute in der Nähe
dann auch natürlich dahin gingen und sagten, na dann tanke ich da,
um denen sozusagen zu helfen,
und um halt das übliche Selfie zu machen an der halben Tankstelle,
was dann jeder haben will. Ja.
Du hast auch einen größeren Angriff mitbekommen, als du in Kief warst, oder?
Genau, das war jetzt vor ungefähr einer Woche, also Donnerstag der 13., glaube ich.
Also die Nacht von Donnerstag auf Freitag letzte Woche.
Also jetzt November 2025, genau.
Für die Historiker.
Genau.
Und das war auch so ein Punkt. Also um das so zu verstehen, man hat so eine
App, die sagt, wenn Luftalarm ist Und es gibt auch große Sirenen überall im
Land, also diese typischen Luftalarm-Sirenen oder wie man sie auch aus dem Stadion halt kennt.
Aber die hört man ein paar Mal am Tag im Normalfall.
Weil zum Beispiel immer, wenn die Kampfjets mit den Langstreckenraketen in Russland
starten, dann kriegt die ganze Ukraine Alarm, weil es irgendwo einschlagen könnte.
Und nach einer Viertelstunde heißt aber doch nicht, ist kein Alarm.
Das heißt, diesen reinen Alarm nimmt man wirklich nur so mittelernst irgendwie.
Und dann gibt es aber halt auch Angriffe.
Da sind halt zwei ganz verschiedene Sachen. Nur Angriff in Kiew hieß bisher,
dass man es entweder gar nicht mitbekommen hat, weil Kiew echt groß ist,
oder dass man weit entfernt wie so ein Donnern gehört hat.
Und dann wusste man, oh, das kam
dicht, da ist irgendwo am Stadtrand was abgeschossen worden. Das selten.
Aber das ist so, woran man sich über die Jahre gewöhnt hat. Und ab und zu gibt
es dann ganz selten mal größere Angriffe. Aber es ist halt was anderes.
Und deswegen, es gab abends Alarm und wir mussten am nächsten Morgen um 5 Uhr
eigentlich aufstehen, war der Plan, weil wir dann noch ein paar Stunden,
also sechs Stunden durch die Ukraine fahren mussten.
Wir sind dann um 0 Uhr ins Bett gegangen und da gab es auch Alarm und es hieß,
es sind Scharhets im Anflug und man sagt sich, ach komm Scharhets,
die schießen die eh rund um Kiew ab und das kriegen wir nicht mal mit. Und dann,
Nicht mal eine Stunde später, also kurz vor 1 Uhr nachts Ortszeit,
gab es dann eine unglaubliche Explosion.
Also man gewöhnt sich so an die Etappen von Explosionen.
Das war so laut, dass ich echt dachte, das Haus fliegt weg. Also irgendwas wahnsinnig laut.
Und dann kam mein Kollege Chris, mit dem ich da war, auch rübergerannt und rief
so raus, raus, raus, lass sofort anziehen.
Und ich hatte halt echt tief gepennt, vorhin gesagt, was ist denn los?
Also mitten in der Nacht?
Mitten in der Nacht, also ein Uhr morgens und er sagt, die haben eine ballistische
Rakete abgeschossen gerade.
Abgeschossen?
Abgeschossen, also irgendwie abgefangen und das ergibt auch so vom Knall her
Sinn, weil das heißt so 500 bis 1000 Kilo Sprengstoff und das ist halt ein Knall,
das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Der Punkt ist auch, Artillerie und Schar hätte so alles oft gehört,
wo man sagt, ich habe eine Idee, das ist weiter weg, das ist nicht so groß.
Und das war wirklich so, man hatte das Gefühl, die ganze Stadt hat einmal gewackelt.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, oh Gott, okay, dann gehen wir echt mal runter in den Bunker.
Also Bunker sagt man immer, es ist meist ein Parkhaus oder eine Metrostation,
die tief ist, also unterirdisch.
Aber außerhalb des Hauses, jetzt nicht im Haus selber.
Genau. Und es gibt da, also man weiß meist, wo ist das nächste Parkhaus,
was drei Minusetagen hat oder die Metro ist halt unglaublich tief in der Ukraine,
weil das halt auch schon für so Fälle angelegt war.
Also in Kiefel.
Genau, in Kiew, genau.
Und ich war ab und zu in den letzten Jahren mal abends in der Metro,
meist wenn ich mit Frau, Also in Kiefel.
Okay, dann haben, also das Gute ist, auch wenn man sich da sicher fühlt und
so, wir haben trotzdem immer jeden Abend den Rucksack gepackt an der Tür stehen
mit Wasser, mit was zu trinken, Pass in der Hose und so, dass wenn was ist,
dass man schnell los kann. Und dann sagt er, nicht übertreiben.
Angezogen. Dann haben wir gesagt, ah, wir haben doch von Süßigkeiten gekauft.
Wenn wir jetzt die Nacht lang in der Metro sitzen, lass mal noch eine Tüte Süßigkeiten
mitnehmen. Da macht man sich Freunde mit.
Sind dann sieben Etagen runtergelaufen in unserem Haus. War auch super schlau, so weit oben zu wohnen.
Weil wir sagen immer, allen im Erdgeschoss ersten Stock, zweiten Stock.
Weil die Scheiß schlagen oben ein.
Aber halt auch, wenn jahrelang nichts passiert ist, sagt man,
na, der Ausblick ist aber geil, lass mal oben wohnen.
So und dann kamen wir unten an, weil stockfinster, weil der Strom auch aus war
und wir guckten uns gegenseitig blöd an und so sagt der, okay,
wo müssen wir jetzt langen, weil wir ausnahmsweise nicht da waren,
wo wir sonst immer wohnen, sondern in einem anderen Stadtteil und da haben wir
uns echt blöd angeguckt und gesagt, keine Ahnung,
weil, weißt du, jahrelang nicht mit der Frage befasst, oh und man wusste immer,
die Metro ist vor der Tür und jetzt ist das erstmal woanders gewesen und wir
haben nicht geguckt, wo da ein Schutzraum ist vorher und dachten,
ah fuck, fuck, fuck. Das tut man ja nicht, aber...
Einmal mit Profis.
Ja, wirklich so. Man sagt, Mann, also so Anfängerfehler, ne?
Okay, während wir dann überlegten, kam eine Shahed über uns und wurde abgeschossen
oder ist irgendwo reingestürzt.
Sie ist ein paar Sekunden später dann explodiert mit dem Scheppern in der Nähe.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, warte, hier um die Ecke ist das relativ teure,
große Hotel. Lass mal da hingehen.
Wir sind hingegangen, aber sie sagt an sich, weißt du, in einem Film wäre das
nachher echt lustig, die Szene, so wie zwei Blöde durch die Gegend laufen und ihren Bunker suchen.
Das Hotel war halt zu, war abgeschlossen, also weil es halt nachts.
Dann haben wir aber die Einfahrt zur Tiefgarage gesehen und da war halt so eine Klingel.
Haben wir da geklingelt und dann kommt halt Jan und sagt, ja bitte,
sagt ja, hallo, können wir rein, weil hier ist gerade eine Schahit runtergekommen.
Ja okay, dann ging halt die Tür auf, sind wir da erst noch durchs Parkhaus geirrt,
weil wir das ja auch nicht kannten, sind halt einfach immer weiter runtergegangen
und dann so drei Etagen tief.
Und da waren dann auch offensichtlich alle Hotelgäste und so weiter und da waren
Betten aufgebaut und standen Wasserflaschen und so.
Das ist so das übliche Setup, so Betten, Tische, Stühle, was zu trinken.
Und man kann auch, wenn Alarm ist, in jeden Schutzraum gehen.
Also jedes Hotel lässt einen rein, jedes Parkhaus, alles. Also man muss halt
nur klingeln oder reinfinden, aber das ist auch total klar, dass man überall hingehen kann.
Und im Normalfall, wenn man so tief sitzt, kriegt man auch nicht viel von den
Angriffen mit, auch in der Metro nicht, weil das ist halt weit draußen und so
und in dem Fall war es so, dass wir das Knallen immer wieder bis ins dritte
Untergeschoss gehört haben, was halt auch,
wirklich selten ist, also so, das läuft nicht ab wie in so einem Zweite-Welt-Kriegs-Film
oder so im Normalfall, wo alles wackelt, sondern man kriegt es gar nicht mit
und guckt auf der App, wann der Alarm vorbei ist und dann haben wir irgendwie,
ich glaube bis 4 Uhr morgens oder so da gesessen und dann gesagt okay,
es scheint ruhiger zu werden also der Alarm ist nicht aufgehoben,
aber es scheppert nichts mehr groß,
lass mal Penn legen, weil an sich müssen wir eine Stunde los,
aber das sollten wir verschieben, weil wir haben nicht viel geschlafen,
dann sind wir halt wieder hochgegangen und es gab noch Warnungen von Scharhetz
irgendwo, aber das heißt halt im Normalfall außerhalb der Stadt,
also dass die nach Kiew reinkommen ist selten und dann,
Dann waren wir also gerade dabei, wieder ins Bett zu gehen und ich habe aber
so einen Brummen draußen gehört.
Und das andere ist, man meint aber auch immer, man hört was,
wenn man das den ganzen Abend hatte.
Und dann dachte ich so, komm, so aus purer Neugierde bin ich dann ans Fenster
gegangen und habe es aufgemacht.
Und in dem Moment schoss wirklich eine Schad über das Haus bei uns. Also so, ich dachte, oh.
So.
Und was man ja als Profi macht, ist erstmal das Handy zücken.
Und ich sagte so, ich habe sie nicht mehr gesehen und die wurde leiser.
Und dann wurde sie wieder lauter, weil sie eine Kurve geflogen ist.
Und dachte so, oh, oh, oh.
Und dann so diese Neugier, wie der Affe mit der Affenfalle.
Der weiß, er müsste jetzt die Faust rausziehen, sonst wird er gefangen,
aber man ist zu neugierig, was passiert.
Genauso halt gedacht, renne ich jetzt los oder filme ich das noch eine Sekunde?
Und genau in dem Moment kam sozusagen von der Seite aus dem Nichts aus meiner
Perspektive auf einmal eine Flugabwehrrakete hoch, also mit dem Feuerstrahl hinten und alles.
Also nicht irgendwas Kleines, sondern wirklich irgendwas, also entweder Iris
T oder SA-8 oder irgendwas in der Größenordnung.
Und also das Ganze war wahrscheinlich zusammen eine Sekunde dieses überlegen,
soll ich wegrennen oder nicht und wie das Ding schoss und so,
aber es kommt einem dann ja so langsam vor, weil es im Kopf so immer langsamer
wird das Ding hat dann die Schad auch erwischt,
und also so in dem Moment, wo sich so optisch die Schad und diese Rakete trafen,
dachte ich, ah ok, alles in Ordnung,
aber Aber ich habe halt zu kurz gedacht, weil das Ding dann ja explodiert mit
100 Kilo Sprengstoff und das war noch so 200 Meter weg von uns,
was für die Sprengstoffmenge nicht viel ist.
Und dann habe ich den Feuerball gesehen und habe noch versucht,
mich wegzudrehen. Aber da kam schon die Druckwelle.
Also so, dass das Fenster aufgeflogen ist und sind Teile bei uns vors Haus geflogen.
Und ein unglaublicher Knall.
Und dann hört man halt danach so dieses Klimpern von allen Teilen, die vom Himmel fallen.
Und überall gehen die Autoalarmanlagen an von der Druckwelle und von Treffern aufs Auto.
Und dann dachte ich, ich gehe mal gucken, was mit Chris ist.
Und der hatte das einzig Sinnvolle gemacht, der hatte Memes geguckt,
die ganze Zeit und Kochsendungen im Bett.
Ist aus dem Bett gefallen, hat es Notebook ins Gesicht gekriegt und lag daneben.
Und hatte sowas passiert?
Ich habe ihm das gesagt und sein erster Gedanke war, oh fuck,
hoffentlich haben die nicht unser Auto getroffen. Weil wir müssen ja eigentlich in fünf Minuten los.
Und er sagt, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Und er sagt, okay, sollen wir nochmal runter?
Und dann eigentlich die gleiche Logik, die man immer hat. Erst sagt man,
es passiert ja gar nichts, es ist ja überhaupt nicht wild.
Dann sagt man, das ist gefährlich. Und in dem Moment, wo es abgeschossen ist,
sagt man, jetzt ist es ja abgeschossen, jetzt muss ich auch nicht mehr los.
Jetzt hat es sich ja erledigt.
Er sagt, okay, lass uns nochmal pennen gehen. Wir haben tatsächlich nochmal
so eine Stunde hingelegt, aber war auch jetzt nicht mehr so richtig an Ruhe zu denken.
Und was wir auch schon aus dem Fenster gesehen haben, weil wir so über Kiew
so halbwegs weggucken konnten.
Wir waren halt sozusagen auf der westlichen Seite, wo im Prinzip die kleineren
Gebäude oder die älteren sind und dann guckt man rüber auf die Seite mit diesen
ganzen Wohnblöcken und also diese, was so Sowjet-Style aussieht.
Also auf der anderen Seite des Flusses.
Genau, also sozusagen die günstige und die teure Seite oder die hübsche und die Wohnseite.
Und da sahen wir auch immer wieder so Brände und Rauch, also zwar im Dunkeln,
aber dass man gesehen hat, gut ist das nicht.
Also es ist wirklich, wirklich anders als sonst.
Dann kam ja auch nach und nach die Meldung, in ein Gebäude eingeschlagen,
in noch eins eingeschlagen.
Und also da war dann auch nach und nach klar, das war echt eine deutlich andere Nacht.
Also so Angriffe gibt es ab und zu in Kiew, aber alle paar Monate oder so.
Also es ist nicht häufig, zwei, dreimal im Jahr vielleicht, dass man sowas erlebt.
Da. Das war schon außergewöhnlich und vor allem eben, dass die Drohnen so weit
in die Stadt gekommen sind, trotz aller Verteidigung.
Das hat mich dann schon gewundert, wie die Russen es offensichtlich mehr und
mehr hinkriegen, dass also wirklich die Flugabwehr zu sättigen offensichtlich,
dass sie dann welche durchschieben können.
Ja, the danger is real und das war jetzt auch nicht eine Ausnahme,
sondern das passiert einfach in letzter Zeit häufiger.
Genau, also es wird mehr und mehr.
Hat das vor allem damit zu tun, dass die Russen mehr angreifen,
dass die Ukraine schlechter verteidigt bekommt, was derzeit angeflogen bekommt,
eine Mischung aus allem?
Ich glaube beides. Also zum einen die Mengen an billigen Drohnen,
die die Russen bauen, ist halt immens.
Also in der Nacht sind glaube ich 500 Scharheads gekommen so ungefähr und 20,
30 Raketen insgesamt von verschiedener Art.
Also sodass der ganze Angriff wahrscheinlich 100, 200 Millionen gekostet hat.
Also jetzt sozusagen Verkaufspreis an Ware, was ja auch irre ist.
Aber um halt ein so eine 30, 40 Dollar Drohne abzuwehren, müssen die Ukrainer
oft halt viel, viel mehr Geld investieren.
Also sagen wir im allerdöfsten Fall, wenn man eine Scharheit mit einem Patriot
abschießt, also was man eigentlich nicht tut, aber wenn es aus irgendwelchen
Gründen nötig ist, dann schießt man so ganz grob eine 3 Millionen Rakete auf
eine 30.000 Euro Drohne.
Und das ist ja genau die Idee davon, den Krieg teuer machen. Und.
Dass man sowas technisch gesehen abwehren kann, haben wir ja vor einem Jahr
oder wann das war in Israel gesehen,
als der Iran diesen Großangriff, diesen angekündigten Großangriff auf Israel
gemacht haben und alle Länder haben geholfen und es ist im Prinzip nichts von
so einer Riesenangriffswelle oder fast nichts durchgekommen,
sagt, das ist ungefähr das gleiche, was in der Nacht nach Kiew kam.
Das heißt, wenn die ganze Welt so mitgemacht hätte wie da bei Israel in dem
Moment, dann hätten wir durchgepennt und das nicht mal mitbekommen.
Also technisch möglich ist es, aber halt teuer, aufwendig und muss halt Wille
da sein. und dann könnte man theoretisch einen ganz großen Teil direkt an der
Grenze abfangen einfach, also mit genug Technik.
Dann wird das überhaupt nicht ins Land kommen oder man müsste noch ganz vereinzelt was machen.
Ja, aber mit dem, wenn man halt immer wie so Flickenschusterei mit den ganzen
Sachen machen muss, ist das halt ein Problem.
Und ich meine ganz einfach, man muss so Systeme nachladen und dann eben verteilen.
Es gibt immer noch die Pickup-Trucks, die irgendwo rumstehen mit einem MG und in die Luft schießen.
Die sind jetzt aber nicht mehr weit vor der Stadt, sondern die sind in der Stadt,
weil die Drohnen halt auf vier bis fünf Kilometer Höhe anfliegen,
meist automatisch auch, also so auf dem Autopiloten.
Und dann kurz vor der Stadt gehen die runter auf knapp über Hausdachhöhe und
werden dann erst manuell übernommen von Piloten.
Und das Videosignal geht dann von Drohne zu Drohne zu Drohne,
also es gibt so Relay-Drohnen und dann bis nach Russland, sodass die also auch,
wenn kein Handynetz oder nichts da ist, immer noch okay gesteuert werden können.
Kann man die in der Stadt noch mit diesen Pickups abschießen,
aber dann stürzen sie halt oft noch in irgendein Gebäude oder in Fluss.
Also sie kommen ja immer noch irgendwo runter.
Man kann nur versuchen, sie in den Fluss zu lenken oder in den Park oder sowas halbwegs.
Und ja, das ist dann eben das Problem. Man übersättigt die Flugabwehr,
sodass die Ukrainer halt echt überlegen müssen, was sie abschießen und halt
die Schahed, die vorn mit einer Rakete abgeschossen wurde.
Weil auch das Ding, da haben die wahrscheinlich auch lange überlegt,
setzen wir jetzt diese teure Rakete ein, die wir nachladen müssen oder knallt
es vielleicht in den Rohbau, was wir akzeptieren können?
Ja, also wie heißt das im medizinischen Bereich so schön, wenn man entscheiden
muss, wen man jetzt zuerst will?
Ach, Triage.
Triage sozusagen, das ist so ein bisschen Flugabwehr-Triage.
Ja, insofern kann man nur hoffen, dass diese Interceptor-Drohnen besser werden.
Ich bin da verhalten optimistisch, weil das ist bemerkenswert,
was man mittlerweile mit Drohnentechnologie hinbekommt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen ein Detektionsproblem,
aber dann natürlich auch eine Rechnung der Masse, weil wenn man jetzt sagen,
es gibt 500 zu verteidigen pro Nacht,
über die gesamte Ukraine verteilt, man weiß natürlich nicht wo,
müsste das ja bedeuten, dass man so, was weiß ich.
Ziehe mir jetzt mal eine Zahl aus der Nase, 5000 von diesen Dingern quer über
die Ukraine verteilt hat, wenn es überhaupt mal reicht, die so gestaffelt verschiedene
Verteidigungslinien darstellen, je nachdem wie weit die auch selber kommen können.
Also man braucht eine gewisse Abstandsdichte, vielleicht ist 5000 sogar noch viel zu wenig.
Also potenziell vielleicht 10.000, die zu jedem Zeitpunkt starten könnten und
dann 500 davon, die im richtigen Moment nah genug dran sind und dann auch treffen,
was ja auch nicht unbedingt gesagt ist.
So könnte sich dann eben so ein Verteidigungsnetz etablieren.
Wobei man natürlich dann auch immer das Problem hat, muss man dazu sagen,
Luftverteidigung ist ja nicht einfach.
Das kann ja schnell mal passieren, dass man was falsch trackt und dann ist der
eigene Hubschrauber dran, das eigene Kampfflugzeug dran. Das will man natürlich
auch vermeiden oder auch sogar die eigenen Raketen, die man losschickt.
Also das bleibt auf jeden Fall ein schwieriges Thema.
Ja, auch zur Rechnung nochmal. Sagen wir mal, so eine Interceptor-Drohne kostet 1000 Euro das Stück.
Eine Patriot-Rakete kostet 3 Millionen. Das heißt, für einen so eine Rakete
könnte man 3000 so Interceptor-Drohnen haben.
Man sagt, dann wird die Rechnung wieder interessant.
Und wenn man die Drohnen dann irgendwo quasi auf Hausdächern parken kann oder
wie man das Deployment dann genau macht.
Man packt die wirklich auf alle Hausdächer um Kiew rum oder um die Großstädte rum.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist halt das Starten, also diesen Prozess starten.
Also die so weit kriegen, dass sie sehr zuverlässig treffen,
sie dann überall verteilen und irgendwie auch so wie Nachlademechanismus haben.
Also so wie hier die Typen, die rumfahren und die Rollerakkus tauschen,
müsste dann ja morgens einer rumfahren und Drohnen nachlegen.
Nur ich glaube, wenn man das einmal sozusagen am Laufen hat,
das System, also wenn man so ein paar Runden durchgespielt hat,
wie es geht, dann ist das im Verhältnis zu Abfangraketen gar nicht so teuer.
Und vor allem, wenn man dieses teure Raketen gegen billige Drohnen damit ausspielt,
weil man eine noch billigere Abwehrdrohne hat und auf einmal ist es für die Russen teurer.
Ich vermute, das Ergebnis wäre dann aber, dass sie die Scharheads dann nicht
mehr fliegen, weil sie genau ihren Punkt, was Teures anzulocken, nicht mehr haben.
Und dann kommen sie mit der nächsten blöden Idee um die Ecke.
Also dann vielleicht kriegen sie irgendeine Idee hin, wie sie billige ballistische
Raketen bauen oder was weiß ich, was der nächste Punkt wäre.
Aber zumindest würde man, denke ich, also wenn man es billig genug schafft,
genau diesen Kampf ums Geld gewinnen, was am Ende halt im Krieg extrem oft ja der Punkt ist.
Weil man kann ja fast alles abschießen, also bis hin zu Satelliten,
wenn man genug Geld und sozusagen Technik reinsteckt.
Und deswegen am Ende ist es ja ganz oft nur die Frage, wer schickt was Teures gegen was Billiges.
Und genau das ist, was die Ukrainer jetzt ja quasi machen. Also es muss unter
30.000 kosten, das 30.000 Ding abzuschießen und dann ist der andere im Nachteil.
Gab es da noch interessante Dinge in Kiew, die du dort besucht und beobachtet
hast oder seid ihr dann weitergefahren, weil das jetzt nur so ein Zwischenhab war?
Ich meine, in Kiew ist man ja eigentlich im Wesentlichen der Kontakte wegen, würde ich sagen.
Genau. Ja, und das war in dem Fall ganz interessant, weil sonst bin ich auch
oft ein paar Tage in Kiew, um Leute zu treffen.
Diesmal aber nicht. Ich war wirklich fast immer nur abends da und morgens wieder
weg und dann zwei, drei Tage weg und wieder da.
Also es war nur der Dreh- und Angelpunkt und dann von da ging es erstmal nach Pavlorod,
das ist so eine kleine Stadt hinter Dnipro und sozusagen, wenn man von Kiew
nach Donetsk früher gefahren ist oder in den Krieg zum Donbass hin seit 2014,
dann kam man halt meist durch die große Stadt den Dnipro und dann durch die
kleine Stadt Pavlorod und das war dann so halbwegs die letzte Stadt,
bevor man dann durch so ganz kleine Kaffs wie Pokrovsk und so kam,
die damals niemand richtig kannte.
Ich glaube, Pokrovsk hatte 50.000, 60.000 Einwohner vor dem Krieg irgendwie
so und Pavlorod ist ein bisschen größer,
aber ist auch keine Großstadt Und derzeit ist Pavlorod sozusagen die letzte
normal erreichbare Stadt,
bevor so ein bisschen Landstraßen, nix kommt.
Und dann kommt halt irgendwann die Front, also nach zwei Stunden Autofahren
oder so, nicht direkt dahinter.
Es ist so sozusagen das Tor zu und ab hier bist du auf dich alleine gestellt.
60.000 waren das mal in Pogrovsk.
Ja, gar nicht so groß. Ja, in Pavlorod ist auch so ein Punkt.
Manche Gegenden in der Ukraine kann man ja einfach als Tourist sozusagen erreichen.
Also man kann sich ja im Großteil des Landes frei bewegen.
Und dann kommen Gegenden wie so Anlieger frei, wo man da nur hin darf,
wenn man einen Grund hat und den nachweisen kann und oft auch eine Erlaubnis hat.
Und Pavlorod ist so der Ort, in dem man noch einfach kann. Und dahinter kommen
dann die Checkpoints, wo man als normaler Mensch nicht weiterkommt.
Und da war ich, und das ist auch immer so interessant, ich habe da Leute vom
Militär getroffen und vorher kann man dann oft nicht sagen, wen und wie und
warum, weil das halt oft sicherheitsrelevant ist. und dann ein paar Tage später ist das nicht mehr.
Und da hatte ich halt Leute von der 7. Army Corp getroffen.
Das ist so ein neuer Armeeteil oder wie man das mal sagt, der nach,
wenn man so will, NATO-kompatiblem Aufbau und Standard jetzt dieses Jahr geschaffen wurde.
Und das ist so was wie so eine schnelle Eingreiftruppe oder so die Feuerlösch-Truppe,
die halt jetzt immer dahin soll, wo gerade was los ist.
Wo es brennt.
Also Rapid Reaction Forces.
Wie heißt die Abteilung noch?
Siebte Army Corps. Der ganze Name ist dann wie immer länger und auf Ukrainisch noch viel schlimmer.
Ja, okay.
Siebte. Genau. Aber das ist so, wie man sie allgemein noch simpel bezeichnet.
Und die kümmern sich derzeit vor allem um Pokrovsk um die Ecke.
Also nicht nur sie, aber das ist sozusagen der erste große Einsatz, den sie jetzt machen.
Und deswegen war es halt für mich interessant, die zu sehen und zu verstehen,
was die da treiben oder was das alles heißt.
Weil ich meine, wenn es jetzt heißt, nach NATO-Standard neu aufgestellt und
so, dann sage ich, ja, mache ich halt erstmal irgendwie Germany auf und frage, was heißt das?
Was tut das? Und wenn man so Leute trifft, ist das Verständnis dann besser.
Und Pavlorod selbst war, also da merkt man schon,
da ist unglaublich viel Militär, weil immer, wenn die ein bisschen frei haben
von der Front oder von der Nähe der Front, kommen sie halt nach Pavlorod,
weil da ist noch Normalität ein bisschen,
da haben die Geschäfte auf, da haben die Restaurants auf, aber man ist quasi
direkt wieder im Einsatzgebiet und auch,
wenn man da mit diesen oft so, mit diesen komischen gespendeten Pickups rumfährt
ohne Nummernschild, die man handlackiert hat und in einer Uniform rumläuft, dann wird man…,
Also überhaupt nicht komisch angeguckt oder gar nicht, während in Kiew ja oft
halbwegs normales Straßenleben tatsächlich ist, wo man damit schon ein bisschen aus dem Rahmen kippt.
Eine lustige Sache war in Pavlorod, als wir da essen waren, stand auf dem Parkplatz
so ein grüner, auch so ein gespendeter Pickup-Truck.
Da stand hinten drauf so gespendet von Jake Bro, wo ich so dachte,
okay, cool, deine Spenden kommen wirklich an, ich hab's gesehen.
Das muss man vielleicht noch dazu erwähnen. Also Jack Bro ist mittlerweile der
sichtbarste YouTuber aus dem Westen, also jetzt nicht innerhalb der Ukraine,
aber der sich außerhalb der Ukraine betätigt, sehr erfolgreich ist mit seinen Spendenaktionen.
Er hat jetzt glaube ich schon sechs oder sieben Aktionen gefahren,
die über eine Million Dollar eingebracht haben und das meiste,
nicht alles, aber das meiste floss genau in diese Pickup-Trucks.
Er hat also mittlerweile schon so eine kleine Armee da rumfahren und es ist
ja üblich, dass solche Spendenaktionen auch immer unter einem Motto stehen.
Es gibt dann immer ein Patch dazu, so ein Army-Patch, was man sich an den Arm
ran machen kann, was für viele auch so ein Sammler-Ding ist.
Ich nehme da immer nicht dran teil, das ist mir nicht so wichtig,
aber ich habe da auch mitgespendet.
Insofern immer schön zu sehen, dass dann diese Fahrzeuge auch real sind.
Gab es keinen Zweifel dran, aber trotzdem gibt es schon so genug,
dass man auch mal auf welche stößt.
Genau und also so zufällig irgendwo, das ist ja mal die Hauptfrage bei Spenden,
kommen die an und bleiben die Sachen da und das kann man ja von außen eigentlich nicht prüfen.
Also egal wie, egal was, am Ende kann man nur darauf vertrauen.
Deswegen fand ich das nur auch gut, den Zufall, wo ich sagte,
jawohl, also auf jeden Fall gibt es die Dinger und sie fahren rum. Und,
Und ein Bekannter von mir ist auch in Pokrovsk selber bei der ukrainischen Armee
und da gerade im Einsatz.
Deswegen hatte ich so ein bisschen immer so Kleinigkeiten von mitbekommen und
die von Armikorps fragten dann,
ob wir denn mit in ein Krankenhaus wollen, was sozusagen auf halber Strecke
zwischen Pavlorod und Pokrovsk ist.
Also so ein ehemaliges Dorfkrankenhaus von irgendeinem Kaff,
was da ist und vielleicht so ein 200 Quadratmeter Gebäude,
wo halt so ein paar Ärzte im Normalfall drin sitzen.
Also Krankenhaus ist ein bisschen ein Hochaufgang, aber das,
was man so als Dorfkrankenhaus nennt.
So ein Versorgungszentrum auf jeden Fall.
Genau, also wahrscheinlich so Hausarzt, Zahnarzt und irgendwie noch was im Normalfall.
Und da kommen halt Verletzte durch und da sind auch so wie so Rettungswagenfahrer,
die dann bis Pokrovsk zum Teil fahren und Leute abholen.
Und ich sage, das klingt interessant, weil haben sie gesagt,
wie weit ist das genau weg? Und sagt, na, so 50 Kilometer.
Man kann sagen, okay, so 20, 30 Kilometer so Artilleriereichweite und die Hauptdrohnenreichweite,
sagen wir mal, derzeit und 50 Kilometer schon so relativ sicher.
Also das ist so, wo man guten Gewissens hinfährt.
Und dann hatten wir auch gesagt, weil Sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind immer unterschiedlich,
können wir die Handys mitnehmen, können wir unseren, wir haben immer so Tracker
bei Satellitentracker, die meinem Büro sagen, wo ich bin und halt,
wenn das Handy nicht ausfällt, auch per Satellit das melden.
Die sagten, ja, könnt ihr alles mitnehmen, aber es funktioniert eh nicht.
Das ist alles gejammt, das GPS auf dem Weg.
Er sagt, okay, aber im Normalfall ist es so, man hat so 90 Prozent,
dass das GPS nicht läuft und dann sieht man mal, wo man ist und dann hat man so einzelne Punkte.
Und in dem Fall war es so, dass wir immer irgendwo in Südamerika angezeigt wurden,
aber in Lima meist, ganz interessant.
Also ich weiß auch mal nicht, was ist der Grund, warum man wo angezeigt wird.
Aber das Interessante war, dass wir wirklich die ganze Nacht lang,
die wir dann unterwegs waren, absolut null Positionsdaten auf null Geräten hatten.
Also gar nichts. Also lückenlos die Position gejammt oder gespooft.
Und das ist auch interessant, weil das früher nicht auf so großer Fläche und
so gut funktioniert hat.
Einer der Hauptpunkte ist eben, dass die Drohnen, also verschiedene kleine und
große und Raketen und so ihren Anflug nicht ordentlich machen können,
weil sie halt nicht genau wissen, wo sie sind.
Die kleinen FPW-Drohen werden dann halt per Kamera geflogen und die Raketen
haben ja oft auch so ein Initial, wer ist das, INS auf Deutsch,
also ein Trägheitsnavigationssystem, sodass sie es immer noch grob wissen,
aber es hilft offensichtlich trotzdem genug.
Der Nebeneffekt für uns war nur, dass ich auch beim besten Willen nicht sagen
könnte, wo wir waren oder jemandem sagen könnte, wo das Krankenhaus ist,
weil ich halt keinen blassen Dunst habe, weil nicht eins meiner Geräte weiß, wo ich war.
Aber fand ich auch interessant, wie die Technik da voranschreitet.
Und in dem Krankenhaus, das war ganz interessant, ein bisschen mit den Leuten sprechen.
Und während wir da standen, sagten die, hey, wir müssen gleich Soldaten abholen.
Wollt ihr mitkommen? Wollt ihr verstehen, wie die Lage vor Ort ist?
Also was meint ihr mit vor Ort?
Also weil gemessen an einem durchschnittlichen Deutschen sind wir schon quasi an der Front.
Aber so wie immer, je weiter man ranzoomt, desto präziser muss man sein.
Und die sagten dann, ja, wir fahren zum Stabilisierungspunkt Pokrovsk.
Okay, nur sorry für die blöde Nachfrage, was heißt das genau?
Weil das kann ja auch sein, dass er 10, 20 Kilometer vor der Stadt ist und der heißt nur so.
Und die sagten, nee, nee, der ist schon an der Stadtgrenze.
Sagt, okay, wie sicher ist das, auch wenn die Frage blöd ist?
Die sagten, naja, es geht schon.
Und das Lustige war nur, der Typ, der gefahren ist, während er mit uns gesprochen
hat, stand er die ganze Zeit da in Flipflops mit einer Jogginghose,
einem T-Shirt an, so einer schussigeren Weste, wirklich so halbherzig drüber.
Im November.
Im November, ja. Also so ein großer, breiter Ukrainer, aber jetzt nicht so ein
trainierter wie die Klitschkurs, sondern so breit vom Waller gerne gut aß offensichtlich.
Mit so Kippe im Mundwinkel und so einem Kaffeebecher in der Hand.
Also wirklich wie so eine Karikatur von einem Ukrainer, wenn man so will.
Aber ein Originaltyp einfach. Der sagt, ich fahre die Runde ein paar Mal die Nacht, ist alles okay.
Er sagt, okay, also offensichtlich, bisher hat er überlebt. Also so falsch kann
er es nicht machen, glauben wir.
Also das ist auch wieder so ein Punkt, man weiß, ey, das ist echt nicht sicher,
aber man muss wissen, wie es da ist, also diese Neugier und diese einmalige Chance,
weil wenn ich irgendwie vorher angefragt hätte, können wir da hin,
nie im Leben sagt einer, klar, wir nehmen dich mit, weil das klappt nicht,
aber dadurch, dass man zufällig da ist, dann ist der Typ da,
der einem vertraut, dann ist also so diese Kette von Sachen,
wo ich dachte, so das ist die Chance, jetzt kann ich den Stabilisierungspunkt sehen oder...
Also das wird es sein. Und dann habe ich gedacht, ich will mit und weil Chris
auch dabei war, habe ich den gefragt und er sagte so, ja, ja,
ja, also du sagst nicht meiner Frau, aber ich bin dabei.
Liegt schon interessant.
Ja, genau, man muss es wissen.
Okay. Also ihr seid dann mitgefahren?
Bis Pokrovsk, ja.
Bis Pokrovsk mit einem Typen in Flipflops, der irgendwie diese Touren macht,
um Verletzte abzuholen.
Genau. Das heißt, ihr seid dann auch quasi wie Rettungswagenfahrer, ja.
Das heißt, ihr seid auch mit Verletzten dann zurückgefahren?
Genau. Wir haben gesehen, wie die da quasi angenommen und eingeladen wurden.
Während die sozusagen die Übergabe gemacht haben, konnten wir eine schnelle
Runde durch den Stabilisierungspunkt selber machen.
Das ist halt auch so wenige Räume, zwei, drei Räume, wo halt Leute angenommen,
eingeteilt, wirklich nur minimal zusammengeflickt und in den nächsten Wagen gepackt werden.
Also wie so eine Durchlaufsache.
Was mich total überrascht hat, das war geleckt sauber, der Laden.
Also ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass da bis unter die Decke Blutspritzer überall
sind und wie in so einem Horrorfilm.
Und es hat unglaublich nach Desinfektion gerochen. Also so als würde das gleich
Feuer fangen, wenn man Feuerzeug anmacht.
Die hatten auch so große Pumpdinger, wie so, womit man die Pflanzen wässert,
so Teil und haben ohne Ende immer desinfiziert und gewischt.
Ich dachte aber, okay, die haben das Zeug da und die haben die Zeit und die machen das.
Also es spricht ja sehr dafür, wie ordentlich das noch läuft,
also dass sie nicht über ihren Kipppunkt sind.
Und da waren auch Leute mit Schrapnell-Verletzungen und Ähnlichem.
Und im Prinzip halt Blutung stoppen, desinfizieren und eine Menge Schmerzmittel
rein. Das waren so die Dinge, die sie da gemacht haben.
Soldaten oder Zivilisten?
Soldaten in dem Fall. Ich glaube, Zivilisten sind da echt fast gar nicht mehr.
Also vielleicht noch hier und da einzeln.
Es gibt ja oft alte Leute, die einfach nicht weg wollen.
Aber das kann fast niemand mehr sein in der Gegend. Also ich war ja vor einem
Jahr noch in Pokrovsk, da war schon unglaublich ausgedünnt und da konnte man
sich in Pokrovsk noch frei bewegen.
Kannst du sagen, wie weit dieser
Stabilisierungspunkt von der Stadt vom Geschehen entfernt war ungefähr?
Also das Hauptproblem ist wieder, ich habe kein Gerät, mit dem ich selber messen konnte.
Aber uns wurde gesagt, es war fünf Kilometer vom Bahnhof etwa.
Und die Angaben, die die uns geben, sind natürlich immer Mittel.
Also es werden irgendwas zwischen 0 und 15 gewesen sein, gehe ich jetzt mal
von aus, weil die ja auch das immer ein bisschen verschwommen machen,
aber sagen wir mal schon dicht am Geschehen.
Also da, wo es schon unangenehm ist, sagen wir mal.
Was ich auch sehr sehr spannend fand, wir durften Fotos machen und filmen überall,
wobei das auch nur ging, weil wir halt mit dem Militär sehr sehr lange schon
zusammenarbeiten und die gesagt haben, hey ihr kennt die üblichen Regeln also ihr wisst wie man,
ihr kennt euch aus, also nichts worüber Standort und Person identifizierbar sind,
aber wir haben da halt zumindest ein paar Fotos machen können mit denen wir
so eine Idee hatten, was los ist.
Und die Fahrt dahin ist auch sowas, das sind halt so Landstraßen mit einer Spur
pro Richtung, mit Schlaglöchern und nicht guten Straßen.
Und die Autos, mit denen man fährt, sind halt meist nicht moderne Fahrzeuge,
sondern entweder sind es halt diese gespendeten Pickups, die aber gerne mal 10, 20 Jahre alt sind.
Oder auch Rettungswagen, da waren welche aus Schweden, Frankreich,
Niederlanden, also alles, was irgendwo gekauft oder gespendet wurde.
Und dann halt ein Fahrer, der mit dem Wagen fahren kann.
Und die fahren dann in der Nacht 140, 150 auf der Straße, aber meist mit Licht
aus und nur Standlicht an, also damit sie so gerade eben sehen,
wo rechts und links die Straße ist.
Ich kenne die Straße halt auswendig, aber es ist schon, man braucht eine Menge Vertrauen zum Fahrer.
Dann sitzt der da mit der Kippe im Mundwinkel und sagt, ja und da hinten,
da ging es mal da und da und da hat mal ein Freund von mir gewohnt und so wie so Sightseeing.
Also der vermittelt schon, dass er weiß, was er tut, aber man sitzt da halt
wie so ein Gepäckstück drin und ist sich nicht sicher, was passiert.
Und dann kommen zwischendurch Autos, die einen überholen, die noch schneller sind.
Also es ist schon so, es ist so ein bisschen wie Achterbahnfahren im Dunkeln,
nur dass man halt hier noch weiß, dass der TÜV fliegende Bauten mal da waren,
da weiß man nicht, ob der Wagen überhaupt noch TÜV hat.
Und ich finde Abblendlicht immer schon nicht zumutbar bei beleuchteten Straßen nachts irgendwie.
Also ich meine, du erinnerst dich ja an die Straßenhaare, so wird hier keine Straße mehr aussehen.
Und dann auf dem Rückweg wurde es aber noch ein bisschen schwieriger,
weil als wir da halt noch Wie gesagt.
Wo wart ihr denn da vor Ort?
Vor Ort, nicht lang, 10, 20 Minuten, also an genau dem Punkt erstmal.
Das war auch so, die haben gesagt, wir können jetzt zurückfahren oder mit der nächsten Runde.
Alles sehr unklar ist ja, wer weiß, wann die kommen und er sagt komm,
also ich bin unglaublich neugierig gewesen, das zu sehen, ich hab's gesehen
danke ich kann auch gerne wieder raus und man hört halt die ganze Zeit das Scheppern
aus Pokowsk in der Nähe und also man merkte wirklich, das ist unmittelbar,
da, wo es rund geht.
Und 5 Kilometer ist halt gar nichts.
Und dann war halt das Problem, als wir da noch mit einem Arzt gesprochen haben,
der uns erklärt hat, wie er da arbeitet,
rief halt jemand in den Raum so oder in dieses Gebäude oder in diesem kleinen
Teil so Jammer, Jammer, so alle Jammer an sofort.
Was halt heißt, also Jammer, also diese Störsender, das heißt Drohnen sind im
Anflug und jeder, der was auf dem Auto hat, um die zu stören, soll es jetzt anmachen.
Sagten wir, okay, wir sind ja schon dicht an der Front. Das heißt,
bis gerade war das noch nicht notwendig. Jetzt hat sich also auf dieser kurzen
Distanz etwas geändert.
Also wo es so sagt, aha.
Und dann sagten die halt, wollte er noch eine Runde warten? Oder er sagt, nee, nee, danke.
Vielen Dank, vielen Dank, alles gut.
Und um diesen Standort dort nicht zu verraten, ist da halt nichts beleuchtet.
Also drinnen schon, aber halt
mit so mehreren Vorhängen. dass nichts rausscheint und draußen gar nichts.
Man kann dann draußen so Rotlichttaschenlampen benutzen, weil das rote Licht
halt schwerer zu sehen ist, also sinngemäß nicht so weit leuchtet.
Die haben sie aber auch noch in unglaublich Dunkel gehabt und haben gesagt,
wir sollen unsere nicht benutzen, weil sie ihre so runtergedreht haben,
wie sie wüssten, dass das gut geht.
Das heißt, ich habe aber gar nichts gesehen draußen, also wirklich nichts.
Das ist aber auch vorgesehen. Dann kam halt ein Typ, echt so groß wie ein Klitschko
und greift dich so an Gürtel und Schulter, rennt mit dir durch die Nacht und
schiebt dich in dein Auto.
Woher weiß der, wo das ist und wie, aber okay, dann ist man drin.
Und welche Distanz hast du in dem Moment?
Mehrere 10 Meter, 20, 30 Meter vielleicht, also so geht.
Aber so richtig Nacht, Dunkel, gar nichts, null.
Stoppfinster, also nicht ein Orientierungspunkt, ob ich gerade auf einer ehemaligen
Tankstelle bin, in einem Krankenhaus, bei einem Privathaus, also null.
Ich dachte, das ist ja auch ein lustiger Sicherheitsaspekt. Ich könnte beim
besten Willen nicht sagen, wie es aussah, weil ich weiß nur, wie es drin war.
Und ich weiß nicht mal, ob es zehn Etagen hat oder eine. weil ich bin nicht
mal bis zu einer Treppe gekommen. Und dann?
Durftest du dort, also wie viele Leute haben da vor Ort gearbeitet?
So 10, 10, 15 so. Also so von Ärzten, sowas wie Pfleger, welche die nur gewischt haben.
Also auch ein ordentliches Setup und alle entspannt.
Also auch nicht so eine Hektik vermittelt, sondern man hatte echt das Gefühl,
die wissen alle haargenau, wie jeder Handgriff geht.
Also wirklich so, es sah nicht aus, als seien sie im Stress,
sondern es sah aus, als würden die einfach ganz entspannt ihren Bürojob machen.
Das fand ich auch irre, weil was für eine Routine müssen die inzwischen haben,
dass sie da einfach ganz gechillt ihre Sachen abarbeiten unter den Umständen.
Das war aber irre zu sehen. Und also genau deswegen war es halt spannend,
das mal gesehen zu haben, um genau diesen Eindruck zu haben,
um diesen Unterschied zu wissen, wie sieht das aus, wie ist das?
Waren das, vielleicht wusstest du das nicht, aber ist das dann Teil des Militärs? Ist das zivil?
Also wer organisiert die, wo hängen die dran?
In dem Fall war es Militär, also komplett, also Soldaten im Medizindienst, im Militär.
Und das war eine, wie nennt sich das, eine Einheit, die zu dieser siebten Army-Korps gehört.
Also da gibt es dann ja so diese ganzen Units, die da irgendwie dranhängen. Und davon war es eins.
War eigentlich, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ein Luftlandebataillon,
aber die halt eben auch Sanitäter, Ärzte, alles mögliche haben und die halt
dieses Krankenhaus oder diesen Stabilisierungspunkt dann besetzen.
Aber es gibt auch welche, wo Zivilisten sind oder sowas wie im Prinzip zivile
Mitarbeiter beim Militär, also zivile Ärzte, die aber jetzt beim Militär arbeiten,
aber eben nicht militärisch verpflichtet sind.
Also es gibt alle Varianten und das war aber rein militärisch der Standort.
Und diese 50 Kilometer, die ihr da überbrücken musstet durch die Nacht in hoher
Geschwindigkeit, gab es dann da noch Kontrollpunkte?
Nee, gar nicht. Das ist auch typisch so, wenn man in dem Fall hinter Pavlorod
sozusagen, also da gibt es meist so den ein, irre streng kontrollierten Checkpoint immer in so Ecken.
Wenn man da durch ist, wird man nicht mehr kontrolliert.
Aber es fragt auch keiner mehr, was man da tut. Weil alle von ausgehen,
es ist klar, dass du irgendwie dahin darfst, dass du es durchgeschafft hast.
Weil zum Beispiel in Pavlorod oder den Nipro fragen Leute noch,
was machst du hier, wozu gehörst du?
Und sozusagen, wenn man dahinter ist, da ist so dieser Bereich mit,
du wirst schon hier hin dürfen und du wirst schon wissen, was du tust.
Das heißt, als ihr losgefahren seid, gab es einen Checkpoint,
wo ihr nochmal vorbei musstet und durftest du dann mit wegen deines Pressestatus
oder durftest du mit, weil der Typ gesagt hat, mit dem Flipflops, das passt schon?
Genau, also weil in dem Fall war es so, ich hatte halt eine Erlaubnis von der
Armee, dass ich mich dort bewege, also unabhängig von meinem Pressestatus.
Also es gibt mit dem Pressestatus, darf ich grundsätzlich überall in der Ukraine
arbeiten, wo nicht die sogenannten Red Zones sind, also da, wo wirklich die
Kampfhandlungen sind, weil da braucht man immer nochmal eine extra Erlaubnis,
weil die einfach sagen, es gibt so viele Deppen bei den Journalisten,
was ich absolut unterschreiben kann,
dass sie einfach nicht jeden Deppen quasi mit dem Mikrofon an der Front rumrennen
lassen wollen, sondern...
Da gibt es verschiedene Ebenen, aber mit einem, der sozusagen dafür zuständig
ist, braucht man nochmal eine Erlaubnis.
Und das ist relativ schwierig, weil sie eben eine Menge schlechter Erfahrungen
mit blöden Leuten hatten. Und dann verstehe ich alles.
Und in dem Fall war es aber so, weil wir halt lange zusammenarbeiten,
habe ich für diesen Bereich, für diese Zeit eine Genehmigung bekommen.
Das ist auch mit Kherson und Sumi zum Beispiel so. Es gibt so verschiedene Ecken.
Es gibt auch viele, wo es nicht ganz klar ist, aber so die Hauptkampfzonen,
die sind fast alle von diesen Beschränkungen betroffen. Und das halt auch.
Das heißt am Checkpoint, das ist ja alles digital, die gucken aufs Kennzeichen,
dann wissen sie, ob das Fahrzeug durch darf oder nicht.
Also in dem Fall war es eh ein Rettungswagen, den sie kennen,
aber ich fahre auch manchmal mit meinem eigenen Auto zu so Sachen hin und dann
scannen die das Kennzeichen und wissen schon mal, das Kennzeichen ist für heute auf der Liste.
Dann gucken die meinen Ausweis an und scannen meist auch einfach diese maschinenlesbare
Zone und dann steht auf dem Tablet, ja, der darf rein. Dann kommt noch einer
und guckt, ob ich es wirklich bin.
Also so der genauer guckt.
Und meist ist es das dann auch schon, weil das relativ einfach geht,
wenn man halt diese Clearance gekriegt hat, weil dann steht eigentlich nur noch
einer da, der prüft, ob das okay ist oder nicht.
Und ab dann ist halt so, ab hier ist dein Problem.
Und oft gucken die ja noch echt bemitleidend an und sagen, ey, viel Glück.
Und dann immer sagt, ja, danke, ich sage Bescheid, wenn ich wiederkomme.
Klar, weil es kann ja alles Mögliche passieren. Ich hätte ja eine Drohne erwischen
können, alles Mögliche.
Ein anderes Fahrzeug hat es auch erwischt auf der Strecke. Also das war auch
einer der Punkte, die haben gesagt, hey, wenn einer in dem Konvoi,
wenn wir rausfahren, erwischt wird, wir halten nicht an. Nur, dass das klar ist.
Also weil, dann kommen ja die anderen Drohnen. Sondern so in diesem Abschnitt,
wenn es dich erwischt, hast du Pech.
Also wenn es dein Wagen erwischt, sieh zu, dass du selber rauskommst.
Und es hat einen anderen erwischt überhaupt auf der Strecke oder in der Nacht?
In der Nacht, also vor uns. Also wir sind mit ein paar Fahrzeugen dann rausgefahren.
Und dann kam per Funk eine Meldung, dass man aufpassen soll,
weil in einem bestimmten Bereich ein Fahrzeug steht.
Und noch keiner genau sagen konnte, blockiert es die Straße oder nicht.
Aber da stand halt ein brennender Wagen, den eine Drohne erwischt hat.
Den habt ihr dann auch gesehen, während er noch brannte.
Und da ist einem dann klar, wie knapp das ist.
Also, es gab noch einen zweiten Punkt in der Art, als der Kollege Christophs
Reasson rausfahren musste.
Da bin ich nicht mit hingefahren. Da hat man es aufgeteilt.
Da sagt einem das Militär quasi, weil man losfahren kann über die Straße raus,
weil die viel bombardiert wird.
Und der Wagen vor ihm ist losgefahren und getroffen worden.
Und dann wird ihnen gesagt, warte mal einen Moment, bis der ausgebrannt ist.
Also da gibt es ein paar so Sachen in der Art, wo man dann immer sagt,
ah gut, es ist vielleicht gefährlich
oder nicht und hin und her und dann sagt man, oh fuck, okay, das,
da war nicht viel Abstand zwischen, das war eine Minute Fahrzeit und die Drohne
nimmt halt das, was sie gerade kriegt.
Das ist einfach nur Glückssache.
Ja.
Wie nimmst du so die Stimmung wahr in so einem Ort wie Pavlorod?
Weil ich meine, das ist ja so ein bisschen, die wissen irgendwie,
die sind dann sozusagen die Nächsten.
Ja, ja.
Merkt man da was von, ich meine, als wir in Odessa waren, es war auf der einen
Seite normales Leben, Aber man merkte auch, diese Stadt hat normalerweise mehr Einwohner.
War das dort auch noch zu spüren?
Ja, in Pavlorod sogar noch anders. Man merkt, das ist fast nicht normales Straßenleben.
Also du siehst da schon ein paar Zivilisten.
Da war auch ein Kinderspielplatz auf dem Kinderspiel. Also das sind so die einzelnen
Dinge, wo man sagt, das sieht normal aus.
Aber dann, das war auch...
Wo es einen dann so zurückholt, weil ich dachte erst, der Kinderspielplatz und so.
Okay, wenn es jetzt nicht fremde Kinder wären und sicherheitsrelevant,
müsste man das eigentlich filmen, um zu zeigen.
Das ist so die Normalität, die da existiert. Und dann mussten die einen gehen
und die eine Mutter stand auf und war auf Krücken und ihr Bein war amputiert.
Und offensichtlich noch frisch und wo man sagte, okay, und das ist dann direkt
wieder der Punkt zurück zur Realität,
weil es würde mich wundern, wenn sie einen Motorradunfall hatte im Winter und
so das Bein verloren hat, sondern höchstwahrscheinlich eine Mine oder Drohne
aufs Fahrzeug oder irgendwas.
Aber der Rest von der Stadt ist die ganze Zeit so ein Trubel.
Also zum einen diese ganzen komischen, selbst lackierten Autos mit Djemmern
und halb kaputt und so, also so diese typischen Frontfahrzeuge.
Und dann auch die Leute, sei es Militär oder irgendwie so aus diesem Dunstkreis,
diese Leute, die dem Militär helfen, so Freiwillige, die irgendwie Hilfsgüter
innerhalb der Ukraine hin und her fahren.
Oder diese ganzen alten Transporter, so Sprinter und so, die hier verkauft werden,
die dann da landen und für so Transporte benutzt werden.
Aber man merkt so, ich würde sagen 80 Prozent der Leute in Pavlo Rott,
die ich gesehen habe, waren, also man merkte, die kommen eigentlich nicht hierher.
Das ist jetzt deren Durchlaufpunkt.
Aber wenn die Front hier rüberkommt, dann gehen die paar Zivilisten noch und
die Leute, die ich jetzt sehe, ziehen halt weiter ins nächste Kriegsgeschehen.
Sodass halt schon Bewegung da war aber man merkt, das ist nicht Stadtleben sondern
das ist wie ein Logistikpunkt einfach nur da wie so ein Durchlaufpunkt für die Leute.
So, wo hat sich denn noch hingeführt nach diesem Ausflug?
Bei, erst in Charkiv, aber das auch nur, weil da die Hotels auf hatten und von da nach Wovchansk,
das ist noch weiter im Osten und Charkiv ist ja so die östlichste Großstadt,
die noch unter ukrainischer Kontrolle im Prinzip ist und ganz dicht,
also so im Nordosten an der Ecke zu Russland,
irgendwie 50 Kilometer oder noch weniger bis zur Grenze.
Und wenn man dann halt noch ein Stück nach Osten geht, kommt Wovchansk und das
ist zur Zeit so umkämpft, weil da im Prinzip eine relevante Straße losgeht,
also die breit genug ist, dass die alle haben wollen,
über die man dann nach Charkiv weiter könnte.
Also ich war nicht im Ort, also nicht da, wo gekämpft wurde,
sondern so 15 Kilometer oder so vom Ort weg, also in einem Gebiet,
was man in dem Bereich als sehr, sehr sicher sieht und habe da halt auch mit,
vor allem mit Leuten von der Armee gesprochen und aber auch wie immer von Rettungsdienst
und Polizei, die einfach da bleiben noch.
Mit denen halt, wie die Lage ist, weil das komische ist, drumherum,
also rechts und links davon sind keine Gegenden, in denen richtig gekämpft wird
zur Zeit, sondern nur dieser Ort.
Das finde ich, sieht auch immer auf diesen Sachen, auf diesen,
also Live-Maps so komisch aus, weil man hat da diesen einen kleinen Ort,
der eine Kampfzone ist und die Grenze zwischen Russland, Ukraine,
rechts und links davon scheint keinen richtig zu interessieren,
weil die einfach nicht, ist halt Wald, also ist gerade nicht so relevant.
Ja, aber ist halt strategisch wichtig. Und dann geht da halt diese,
so eine Landstraße oder so raus, die dann halt am Ende Richtung Rakiv geht und
die ist wohl das Relevante, was die Russen gerne hätten, weil das so der Startpunkt
wäre, um dann über den Fluss und dann bis Rakiv irgendwie zu kommen.
Hier so irgendwie lang. Genau, und,
Und das war ganz interessant, vor allem weil da Drohnen, also so FPW-Drohnen,
geringeres Problem sind als zum Beispiel in Pokrovsk.
Die sagen aber wahrscheinlich, weil fast alle Drohnen in Pokrovsk sind, sozusagen im Einsatz.
Also muss man ja auch am Ende verteilen.
Und das andere Problem war, oder nicht ein Problem, was zum Glück sie gelöst gekriegt haben.
Sie kriegen inzwischen eine Menge russischer Beobachtungsdrohnen,
also Sala und Supercam und sowas, per elektronischer Kriegsführung runter.
Und das fand ich ganz interessant, weil mich interessiert hat,
wie genau, also was genau? Da wollten sie sich aber nicht so in die Karten gucken lassen.
Der nächste Punkt war dann, dass sie gesagt haben, ja...
Sie kriegen die am Stück runter, also ohne dass die kaputt gehen.
Das habe ich zigmal gehört. Ich habe aber ganz selten nur so Drohnen gesehen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich will ja ungern hier alles in Frage stellen,
aber könnte ich mal so ein Ding sehen?
Also so einfach, um eine Idee zu haben. Dann haben die mir so eine Supercam-Überwachungsdrohne
gezeigt, also so eine Flügeldrohne mit dreieinhalb Meter Spannweite und dann
halt einer großen Kamera mit 30-fach optischem Zoom und so, die man halt benutzt,
um dann Ziele festzulegen,
die man bombardieren will.
Das Ding kann auf vier, fünf Kilometern ein paar Stunden seine Runden drehen
und kann dann halt sagen, bomb mal hier, bomb mal da.
Ich sagte, okay, das Ding war wirklich komplett erhalten und gar nichts dran.
Das war jetzt nur eins, das war interessant zu sehen.
Und dann kam das Allerüberraschendste, dann sagten die, willst du die haben?
Sagt, natürlich, ich will so Dinger immer haben.
Und sagt, ja, dann nimm mit fürs Museum.
Also wie? Moment mal. Er sagt, nee, ernsthaft, was sollen wir damit?
Wir haben ein paar von den Dingern, kannst du mitnehmen. Und dann haben die
mir echt so eine dreieinhalb Meter Supercam-Drohne in den Kofferraum gepackt.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, okay.
Ist das nicht wieder Spaß an der Grenze?
Genau das. Also kann man nicht einfach mitnehmen. Wir lassen jetzt gerade die
Exportpapiere und so machen. Das dauert immer ein bisschen.
Okay, also ihr habt sie dann nach Kiew gebracht.
Genau, ins Lager. Und dann, wir wissen ja inzwischen, wie der Exportprozess geht.
Aber ich dachte so, okay, also wenn ich nicht so blöd nachgehakt hätte,
hätte ich jetzt keine geile Drohne gekriegt.
Habe, fand ich halt auch irre.
Und das fand ich aber spannend, dass sie also wirklich nachweislich die Dinger
am Stück runterkriegen, aber sie wollten halt nicht sagen, wie,
was und wo genau, wie das funktioniert.
Das hätte mich halt doch mal brennend interessiert.
Da war ich aber auch nur morgens hingefahren, halben Tag mit denen verbracht
und dann wieder zurück, weil das halt alles halbwegs unsicher ist.
Also es ist immer, man steht da in irgend so einem Dorf und es fühlt sich überhaupt
nicht unsicher an, weil es passiert ja in dem Moment gar nichts.
Aber 10 Kilometer weiter ist es gefährlich und 10 Kilometer ist halt was,
was so eine Rakete, Artillerie oder so eine Drohne schnell fliegen kann.
Und dann habe ich die Nacht halt in Charkiv verbracht und am nächsten Morgen
sind da auch mehrere Schahets in Charkiv eingeschlagen, was da aber relativ
oft passiert wegen der Nähe zu Russland.
Also es sind halt keine 50 Kilometer bis zur Grenze, das heißt da ist die Vorwarnzeit
auch immer unglaublich kurz.
Was ich da aber so irre fand, bin dann am Morgen zu einer von den Einschlagstellen
gefahren, um mir das halt anzugucken.
Also es ist interessant, um so zu sehen, werden die Löcher größer oder kleiner?
Haben sie irgendwas bombardiert, was zumindest militärisch ist oder nicht?
Es gibt halt ganz viele so Dinge, warum es für mich einfach wichtig ist,
das ja immer wieder mal anzugucken.
Und in dem Fall war es so, das war so ein Transportunternehmen,
so eine Lagerhalle einfach, also wahrscheinlich zufällig da reingekracht.
Also jetzt unwahrscheinlich, dass das das Hauptziel war.
Und da waren zum Zeitpunkt des Angriffs 15 Leute und die sind aber,
als der Alarm kam, in den Bunker, also so einen Schutzraum draußen gegangen.
Da habe ich gedacht, die haben ein paar Mal am Tag Alarm und habe die dann auch
gefragt, geht die echt jedes Mal in den Schutzraum?
Und sie sagen, ja, ja, und halt seit Jahren ist nichts passiert und seit Jahren
gehen sie ein paar Mal am Tag in den Schutzraum und dieses eine Mal war es genau richtig.
Und das fand ich halt auch so irre, diese Disziplin, weil die meisten Leute
gehen halt echt nicht mehr in die Schutzräume, weil es zu viel ist.
Und eine Stunde nachdem die Schahe da eingeschlagen ist, waren schon die ersten
Scheiben in den umliegenden Häusern repariert.
Das fand ich halt auch irre, weil die Ukrainer da so eine Routine haben.
Das heißt, da kommt dann so ein Laster wie vom Baumarkt mit ganz viel so Holzplatten.
Und dann haben die einen Generator bei und Kreis- und Stichsägen und Leute,
die es ausmessen und die das halt den ganzen Tag im Team machen.
Das heißt, der eine brüllt runter die Fenstermaße, der andere sägt es zurecht und es passt.
Allein das ist für mich faszinierend, weil bei mir passt das nie, egal wie ich messe.
Ja, so und dann machen die da zack, zack, zack die Fenster,
die rausgeflogen sind mit Holzplatten zu und das halt, also wenn man dann am
Mittag da vorbeikommt und morgens ist was eingeschlagen, ist mittags die Straße
gefegt und die ganzen Häuser sind zumindest sozusagen vorerst repariert.
Und das ist halt auch, also ich kenne es halt aus anderen Kriegsgebieten,
so zum Beispiel im Irak, da kann man zum Teil auf Google Maps sehen,
so hier ist der Panzer, der 1970 abgeschossen wurde und der steht immer noch da.
Oder das Haus von meinem Opa, wo mal ein Fenster kaputt ging und es ist immer noch kaputt.
Also das ist, was ich aus anderen Gegenden gewohnt bin und dann kommt man in
die Ukraine und wenn du zu lange pennst, dann hast du den Einschlag und die Reparatur verpasst.
Es ist Wahnsinn, wie die immer daran arbeiten, so wieder Normalität herstellen,
weitermachen und nicht sagen, das lohnt jetzt ja nicht.
Hast du mal mit jemandem darüber gesprochen, warum sie das so machen?
Ich könnte es mir jetzt denken, aber hast du das mal so gehört?
Sie sagen halt, wir wohnen doch hier. Willst du vor einer dreckigen Straße wohnen
oder mit kaputten Fenstern? Ich denke, ich wohne in Berlin.
Also ich kenne dreckige Straßen und kaputte Fenster.
Es ist halt nicht wie die Front, wo aufgeräumt wird.
Wir müssen mal Berlin auf ukrainischen Frontstandard bringen,
damit es hier wieder ordentlich aussieht.
Wirklich, aber die sagen halt, du willst doch, also das und auch dieses,
den Russen das nicht geben,
dass Schäden zu sehen sind, sondern sagen, nee, nee, nee, ihr wollt,
dass unser Leben zu Ende ist, ihr wollt, dass das kaputt ist,
ist nicht, machen wir nicht. Wird repariert.
Ähm, also genau das nicht. Und deswegen auch, es gab, das ist jetzt glaube ich zwei Jahre her,
in Kharkiv, also was echt eine viel angegriffene Stadt ist, damals den Rave
vor Bachmut, also die Solidaritäts-Rave-Party für Bachmut, sagt,
ihr werdet selber ausgebombt, da vorne wird mehr gebombt, das heißt,
ihr macht das Charity-Event für die, so und macht da Party,
sagen, ja, musst ihr ab und zu feiern und für einen guten Zweck eh,
also die machen halt weiter, ne, weil die sagen, das ist doch,
was die Russen uns nehmen wollen. Und genau das machen wir nicht mit.
Das finde ich aber irre, weil man sagt theoretisch, klar.
Aber das in der Praxis auch nach fast vier Jahren oder im Donbass halt nach
elf Jahren so durchzuziehen, finde ich spannend, wie man seine Moral selber so hochhalten kann.
Und das ist auch, was wir bei diesem Angriff in Kiew gesehen hatten.
Russland schickt halt alles, was sie haben, um die Moral runterzudrücken.
Und das Einzige, was ist, dass wir mit einer Tüte Süßigkeiten da unten sitzen
und die Ukrainer sagen, boah, so davon lassen wir uns hier nicht beeindrucken.
Jetzt rücken wir noch dichter zusammen und keine Heizung, egal.
Dann mache ich den Ofen an und keinen Strom. Na gut, ich habe einen Generator.
Aber es schweißt die Leute, die noch da sind, halt unglaublich zusammen.
Und in Bachmut oder am Eingang zu Bachmut steht wohl ein Schild,
also ich habe nur ein Foto gesehen, weil so weit vorne war ich nicht.
Und da steht halt drauf, wir müssen nur einen Tag länger durchhalten als die.
Und das ist halt gleich genau das, was die Ukrainer die ganze Zeit so motiviert,
genau das. Also so einen Tag länger und dann ist es wieder unsers.
Das beobachtet man schon die ganze Zeit, aber ich denke es ist auch wichtig, dass man dazu sagt,
das mag das generelle Thema sein, aber ich kann mir auch genauso vorstellen,
dass es sehr viele Leute in der Ukraine gibt, die von diesem Krieg schon seit
vielen Jahren komplett überfordert sind.
Und die enorme mentale Schäden davon haben und akkumulieren mit jedem weiteren Tag,
mit jeder weiteren Nacht, die das so läuft.
Also auch Leute, die ich kenne, bei denen ich es auch in den letzten Jahren
gesehen habe, wie das runtergeht. Aber sozusagen beides parallel.
Also wenn man die fragt, wie ist das, willst du weg? sagen die,
nee, das ist mein Land und ich bleibe hier und ich ziehe das durch.
Und aber gleichzeitig, wo man halt merkt, dass die echt, dass es denen einfach,
also so wie so Depressionen, wo man sagt, wenn du mit einem depressiven Menschen
zu tun hast, du kannst ja auch einen lustigen Abend in der Kneipe mit dem haben.
Das heißt ja aber nicht, dass die Depression nicht darunter liegt irgendwie.
Und genau das fiel, ich glaube, bei ganz vielen auch, nicht mal so abstrakt
der Krieg oder so, Sondern so wie viele Menschen, die verloren haben in ihrem Umfeld.
Also erst ist es jemand, mit dem man vor zehn Jahren zur Schule gegangen ist, wo man sagt, okay.
Und dann kommt es näher und näher und näher. Und eine Freundin von mir hat ihren
Mann verloren, während sie dabei war.
Und das sind halt so Sachen, wo man merkt, klar, so mit das Schlimmste, was man mitmachen kann.
Und die macht jetzt aber auch weiter und die wohnt noch da, aber wo man halt
auch klar merkt, da geht es natürlich nicht gut.
Also so und das ist ja auch nicht, dass man sagt, ach komm, Schwamm drüber ist
ein Jahr her, sondern so man lernt mit umzugehen und man macht weiter und sagt
halt trotzdem, ich bleibe hier und jetzt mache ich erst recht weiter,
weil sonst war das ja für nichts sozusagen. Sonst.
Aber sind wirklich viele im Umfeld, wo man auch merkt, das ist nicht so gut.
Oder auch, wenn ich einfach mit denen auf WhatsApp oder so schreibe und man
merkt die Antworten so ein, zwei Tage nicht, was oft ein schlechtes Zeichen
ist, weil sie dann sich nicht mal aufraffen können, so zu antworten.
Und deswegen, was ich dann halt bei vielen mache, ich schicke denen immer Fotos
aus Berlin, was hier Lustiges los ist. Keine Ahnung, die Eisbude oder was weiß
ich, irgendwelche Sachen, irgendwelche schönen Sachen, die hier passieren,
um sich mal so dran zu erinnern, die Welt da draußen ist noch gut.
Und das merke ich immer wieder so, das freut die auch, dass die halt sehen,
okay, man kann auch Spaß haben, es geht weiter und jemand denkt an mich,
jemand teilt seinen Alltag mit mir.
Aber das ist eben sehr wenig, was man dann machen kann, nur so um eben zu zeigen, ich habe dich im Kopf.
Ich weiß, du bist noch da. Und auch bei einem Bekannten, ich glaube,
der hat mir zwei, drei Wochen lang nicht geantwortet.
Aber ich habe ihm halt jeden Tag so ein, zwei Bilder geschickt,
so was ich mache oder irgendwas.
Und dann hat er nach ein paar Wochen geantwortet und sagte halt auch,
ja, es war echt nicht gut die letzte Zeit bei mir.
Also meist wollen die Leute auch nicht sagen, was los ist. Sondern sagen einfach,
hey, sorry, war nicht gut.
Aber hey, danke, dass du an mich gedacht hast, weil zumindest hast du mich nicht
vergessen, weil ich mich nicht bei dir gemeldet habe oder warst noch sauer oder
sagst, was soll das oder so.
Und ja, aber da merkt man schon, also es ist so ein Hin und Her oder eben auch
diese Sachen parallel, also dass man bleiben will, dass man sagt,
wir gewinnen am Ende, aber dass es trotzdem im Kopf nicht gut geht.
So, das waren jetzt also auch zwei Eindrücke von Frontbereichen.
Pukrovs ist sicherlich gerade so der totale Hotspot, hat man ja auch schon angesprochen.
Da geht es den Russen mal wieder sozusagen darum, mal so einen Punkt zu machen
und derzeit ist es auch schwierig, weil auch das Wetter, glaube ich,
gerade den Russen sehr in die Karten spielt.
Üblicherweise in den ersten Jahren des Krieges war es ja oft so,
ja okay, jetzt haben wir hier so die Zeit, wo es kalt ist, beziehungsweise vorher
die Matsch-Saison, da kommt ihr mit eurem Panzer sowieso nicht weiter und es
ist auch irgendwie schwierig, bei niedrigen Temperaturen voranzukommen.
Jetzt ist es eher so, dadurch, dass das ja alles so ein.
Kleinkrieg geworden ist, wo so kleine Gruppen, zwei, drei, vier Leute immer
vorgeschoben werden, die Russen werden einfach nach vorne geschickt.
Ihr lauft jetzt so lange, bis ihr nicht mehr weiterkommt.
Und das ist ja dann sozusagen auch die Antwort auf diese Realität des Drohnenverteidigungskrieges,
dass die eigentlich nur noch in so kleinen Gruppen vorankommen,
aber meistens dann eben doch von der Drohnensituation aufgehalten werden.
Aber jetzt haben wir so ein Herbstwetter, sehr viel Nebel und es gab jetzt gerade
so eine Woche, glaube ich, wo extrem viel Nebel war und dann hilft halt auch, sagen wir mal,
diese Drohnenverteidigung auf einmal nicht mehr so sehr viel,
weil alles quasi kameragestützt ist und sie alle keine geschlossenen Reihen,
alle 20 Meter steht da ein Verteidigungstrupp, so ist es da ja nicht.
Und deswegen kommt die Stadt zunehmend Maße unter Bedrängnis.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen, wie lange das jetzt noch hält. Das kann nächste Woche vorbei sein.
Das kann auch genauso gut noch zwei, drei Monate so weiter gehen.
So war es ja bisher eigentlich überall.
Und insofern ist das nicht schön. Trotzdem kann man auch festhalten,
die Fortschritte der Russen sind im Vergleich zu dem Aufwand, der da getrieben wird.
Kein Verhältnis.
Es ist absurd.
Es gab doch diese Rechnung, dass eine Schnecke inzwischen seit Kriegsbeginn
weitergekommen wäre als die Russen.
Die Schnecke hätte die ganze Ukraine durchschritten.
Ja genau und das fand ich nur so, weil das ist ja immer so kompliziert zu erklären.
Mit der Schnecke denke ich, das ist so sinnbildlich. Also das versteht halt jeder.
Und auch zu dem Nebel und so, ist ja ganz lustig, da kommt ja der Begriff Bombenwetter her.
Also aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, wenn die Sonne scheint, konnten die Bomber sehen,
wo sie hinfliegen. Und dann war Bombenwetter, also es war ein negativer Begriff.
Und war da das gleiche, wenn wir Nebel hatten, haben wir gesagt,
gut, lass mal die schwierigen Strecken fahren und zum Beispiel,
wenn die Sonne scheint, willst du nicht nach Raison fahren, weil dann ist halt Bombenwetter.
Mhm.
Ja, und jetzt zählt nicht mehr so das Bombenwetter, sondern mehr das Vorstoßwetter.
Also jetzt ist es schon deutlich matschig. Also jetzt war noch so Matschzeit,
noch nicht gefroren Zeit, als wir da waren.
Aber das merkt man auch, also auch bei unseren normalen Wagen,
wo wir dann, wir fahren halt manchmal ein Stück über Feld oder so und im Sommer
kann man das Ganze mit dem Golf, die Strecken fahren, ist kein Ding.
Jetzt mussten wir halt die Pickups nehmen mit den groben Stollen drauf und dann
in einem Monat oder so können wir da nicht fahren, bis es wieder gefroren ist.
Also es ist auch so hin und her, aber halt wenn wir mit dem Pkw das Problem
haben, ist klar, mit dem Militärgerät, die kommen da nicht gut durch gerade.
Jetzt warst du aber auch noch in einer anderen Region, warst du noch in Sumi?
Genau, ganz im Nordosten sozusagen.
Das ist auch so eine Stadt, die seit, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht wie vielen Jahren,
also quasi seit Kriegsbeginn immer unter Dauerfeuer und es gibt so ein bisschen
bessere und ein bisschen schlechtere Phasen, aber die sind halt auch ähnlich
wie Rakew, fast unmittelbar durchgeführt.
Fast unmittelbar an der Front, unmittelbar in Russland und deswegen ist das so problematisch da.
Und da ist es auch so eine Red Zone, wo wir eine Einfahrerlaubnis und alles mögliche brauchen.
Für die Stadt selber?
Für den Oblast sogar. An der Oblastgrenze, da ist vor, ich glaube,
Poltava Oblast, das meine ich, der, den man durchfährt. Und dann kommt der Checkpoint,
der ist so anderthalb, zwei Stunden vor der Stadt.
Anderthalb Stunden, glaube ich, ungefähr. Und da ist wie die Vorkontrolle.
Also das ist so wie ein bisschen wie Anlieger frei.
Da ist die Kontrolle, wo sie fragen, ob ich nachher überhaupt nach ob ich eine
Einfahrterlaubnis habe oder ...
Wo ich genau hin will und würde ich an dieser Vorkontrolle sagen,
hallo Leute, ich muss irgendwie da meine Oma besuchen und ich kann das sinnvoll
erklären und das liegt nur ein Stück hinter eurem Checkpoint,
dann würden die mich noch durchlassen.
Wenn ich jetzt aber Ausländer bin und sage, ich muss nach Sumi,
dann sagen die, hey, ich brauche deine Sumi-Erlaubnis, weil sonst ergibt es
ja keinen Sinn, also so wie so eine Transitstrecke, sonst ergibt es ja keinen
Sinn, dass ich dich hier durchlasse.
Und dann gibt es nochmal den Einfahrt-Checkpoint Sumi, wo man halt dann die
gleiche Kontrolle nochmal hat.
Und dann ist es aber auch so, wenn man durch den Checkpoint durch ist,
dann fragt wieder keiner mehr, was man da treibt, weil dann ist man ja kontrolliert.
Und in Sumi habe ich vor allem so zivile Projekte angeguckt,
also so Locals, die irgendwie helfen.
Und das eine war so eine Art Suppenküche, würde man hier wahrscheinlich sagen.
Also einfach so Fütterungen für die, die gerade kein Geld haben.
Das sind im Kern zwei ältere Damen, die einfach kochen, Eintopf, Brot, alles Mögliche.
Die aber jeden Tag 500 Leute versorgen. Also die Menge fand ich mal irre,
wie man da mit ein paar Leuten so das kochen kann.
Und dann aber auch, die waren so 60 und 70.
Fragt ganz praktisch, woher weiß man, dass das hier ist? Also seid ihr was Offizielles
von der Stadt oder ist das privat? Und sie sagten, sie machen das rein privat mit Spenden.
Aber es ist ganz einfach, sie haben halt einen Telegram-Kanal, über den läuft das.
Da dachte ich wie immer so, weißt du, in Deutschland heißt es immer so,
ja, aber die Leute über 50, die können ja nicht einen Computer anmachen.
Wie sollen die das wissen?
Und da ist die 70-Jährige und sagt, abonnier doch meinen Telegram-Kanal,
dann weißt du, was es zu essen gibt.
Das finde ich immer wieder so, wie so Technik da normal einfach im Alltag ist
und das alle benutzen, also so bestimmte Sachen.
Dann war ich bei einem Projekt, die machen Tarnnetze, also die man dann,
die knüpfen die sozusagen und das ist so ein Produkt.
Ich habe erst gedacht, warum kauft ihr die nicht bei Amazon, weil das ist so billig.
Bei ganz vielen Sachen, die ich mitbekomme, wenn Leute solche Projekte machen,
dann machen sie was wie eine Beschäftigungstherapie und es wäre billiger,
das einfach auf Amazon zu bestellen. Also selbst wenn man die Arbeitszeit nicht
berechnet, sondern der reine Materialpreis.
Und deswegen gucke ich mir sowas gerne an und versuche dann höflich nachzuhaken.
Also man will ja nicht sagen, das lohnt sich nicht, aber so.
Warum macht ihr das so?
Genau. Und dann kam raus, die haben das so unglaublich gestreamlined,
ihren Prozess, dass sie ein Viertel von einem Amazon-Netz quasi kosten bei dem, wie sie es machen,
weil sie einfach so 300 Meter Rolle von bedrucktem Tarnstoff quasi kaufen.
Und dann hätte man aber einfach nur eine Stoffbahn.
Dann muss das ja wie so angeschnitten werden, dass es so ein Tarnnetz ergibt.
Und dafür haben sie aber eine Fabrik in der Nähe, die eigentlich ganz andere
Sachen macht, die aber eine, quasi eine Maschine, die sie überhaupt mit so einer
Art Klinge ausstatten konnten, dass sie ihnen die Schlitze so machen,
dass es ein Tarnnetz ergibt.
Und diese Rollen kaufen sie aber dann noch direkt vom Hersteller irgendwo in
großen Mengen und auf einmal kostet das nichts mehr und dann waren ganz viele
Schritte, sie konnten das Haarklein erklären und auch genau,
was das wie wo kostet und wo ich dachte, boah,
ich war so voreingenommen und dachte, okay, das ist wieder so eine Beschäftigungstherapie
und dachte, nee, die haben das echt so durchorganisiert und überall noch einen
halben Cent abgeknipst und so.
Dass das richtig Sinn ergibt. Und Sie sagten, der andere Punkt ist,
Was sie halt vor allem machen, sind sozusagen Netze customizen.
Also wenn du sagst, wir haben hier ein Haus und dann da eine Ecke und hier geht
es hoch und dann muss aber da noch irgendwie irgendeine ganz komische Form gebaut
werden oder so, dann bauen sie halt genau das Netz,
was du brauchst oder mit der Ecke oder dem Ausschnitt oder so oder komische Größen,
oder sowas vorkeninfektioniert, dass du es quasi eine ganze Hauswand runterwirfst,
aber alle Fenster genau ausgeschnitten sind und sowas schon. Ich dachte, okay.
Und auf einmal macht das Projekt total Sinn, weil die einfach richtig viel darüber nachgedacht haben,
wie sie es bis ins Detail optimieren und etwas tun, was du nicht einfach auf
Amazon kaufen kannst. Und das ist auch wieder spannend.
Deswegen muss man halt so vor Ort sein, dass man so diese Details mitbekommt.
Und da auch in Sumi ist eine Partnerorganisation, der wir immer wieder Hilfe
liefern, also Erste-Hilfe-Kits oder ähnliche Sachen, schusssichere Westen für
die Stadtreinigung und für Rettungskräfte und sowas.
Das ist auch immer interessant zu gucken, sind die Sachen noch da?
Also es mag sehr blöde klingen, aber die Hauptfrage ist halt immer,
wenn man was spendet, kommt das an und bleibt da.
Und in der Ukraine gibt es halt so viele Scammer, also jetzt nicht Leute,
die am Ende die Sachen annehmen, es gab halt so viele Sammlungen von Leuten,
die nicht mal in der Ukraine waren, die irgendwelche Fake-Bilder benutzt haben und sonst was,
dass wir immer wieder von Leuten hören, ich würde ja gern spenden,
aber wenn man sich nicht tief mit befasst, wem kann ich vertrauen, wem nicht.
Deswegen kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass Leute wie Jake Brow so viele zu
große Sammlungen machen können. Man sagt, dem traue ich.
Also der Kette dahinter traue ich dann auch so.
Und dann hat man eben so ein paar große Sammler.
Und dadurch, dass wir dann hinfahren, sehen wir aber, die Westen,
die wir geliefert haben, sind noch da. Die Erste-Hilfe-Kits sind noch ein paar
da, ein paar benutzt oder so.
Deswegen ist es halt auch so, es sind immer elendige Fahrten durch die Ukraine.
Das Land ist riesig und man kann nicht so schnell fahren und dann müssen wir
diese Kontrollen haben mit den Checkpoints und so aber genau dafür diese Leute
kennenlernen, wissen, dass das Projekt sinnvoll ist und gucken,
kommt unsere Hilfe an, ist die noch da,
und in dem Fall war auch so, wir waren dann schon 10, 12 Tage oder so da und
ich bleibe immer nur so lange in der Ukraine, wie ich was zu tun habe weil ich
denke, es ist alles latent gefährlich und zum anderen habe ich ja auch noch
Arbeit in Berlin zu machen.
Und wenn erledigt, dann erledigt.
Und in Sumi war dann so, dass wir beide gesagt haben, hey, wir haben nichts
zu tun, dann lasst uns von Sumi aus nach Berlin zurückfahren.
Und im Normalfall wäre das von Sumy nach Kiew 6-7 Stunden, je nachdem wie man durchkommt.
Und dann pennt man meist in Kiew, dann fährt man, von Kiew gibt es dann keine
Checkpoints bis Lviv, da fährt man nochmal 6-7 Stunden nach Lviv,
also an der polnischen Grenze fast, dann pennt man da.
Und dann fährt man mit Grenze und allem so 12 Stunden oder sowas durch nach Berlin.
Also 10 bis 15, je nachdem wie man durchkommt.
Und wir haben mal gesagt, boah, kein Bock auf drei Tage Rückweg.
Das heißt, wir sind dann von Sumi nach Lviv gefahren, ich glaube elf,
zwölf Stunden oder sowas.
Wir sagten, hey, am Ende, die Strecke ist gleich lang.
Lass uns einfach morgens losfahren und abends da sein, dann haben wir nur einen
Tag bis zur Grenze. Aber da merkt man dann immer, wie lang und groß dieses Land ist.
Und auch so städteplanerisch oder verkehrstechnisch die Planung.
Wenn man dann von Sumi nach Lévi fährt, fährt man durch Kiew am Maidan vorbei,
durch die Innenstadt, weil es nicht eine Umgehungsstraße gibt, gar nichts.
Also man fährt, also ist so wie wenn man, keine Ahnung.
Das ist diese riesige Straße, die so mitten nach die Stadt reinführt.
Ja genau, die hat zehn Spuren oder so.
Das ist auch im Osten sehr beliebt. Ich weiß gerade, in Albanien, Tirana ist genauso.
Und es gibt theoretisch sowas wie einen Stadtring um Kiew, aber das ist auch
keine Autobahn oder so, es ist einfach nur eine große Straße,
die im Ring drum rum geht, die genauso zu ist.
Das ist so aus unserer europäischen Sicht mit Umgehungsstraße und eine Zubringer-Autobahn
und was man halt so kennt.
Würden die sicherlich auch ganz gerne mal bauen, aber das war jetzt nicht so im Fokus.
Nee, nee, aber deswegen zieht sich das auch oft so.
Oder dann auch, wenn man von Kiew nach Lviv zur Grenze fährt,
fährt man halt nicht eine Autobahn, dann fährt man ein Stück eine Autobahn.
Das ist auch lustig. Die Ukraine hat offiziell drei Autobahnen.
Das andere sind Landstraßen oder so.
Nein, umgekehrt. Es hat zwei Autobahnen. Und zwar hat es die Autobahn 1 und 3.
Wo ich auch dachte, okay, und die zwei ist... Das ist nicht fertig geworden.
Was man sich auch so fragt, was war da los? Okay, und deswegen,
man fährt dann halt von Kiew nach Lviv auch ein Stück, was so Autobahn ähnlich ist.
Dann fährt man weiter auf zwei Spuren pro Richtung mit Standstreifen und Mittelstreifen.
Und da ist aber 50, weil es eine Ortsdurchfahrt ist. Das habe ich zum Glück
beim ersten Mal gelernt, als uns vor Jahren die Polizei angehalten hat und das
zum Glück noch freundlich erklärt hat, dass das allen am Anfang passiert.
Und dann merkt man halt, okay, da hat man eine Ortsdurchfahrt nach der anderen.
Und später ist es dann aber nicht mal mehr wie so eine Autobahn,
sondern du fährst echt durch so eine Dorfstraße.
Das ist doch hier die Verbindung von Polen, wo die vierspurige Autobahn ankommt,
an der Grenze endet und dann geht eine Spur pro Fahrt Richtung Landstraße auf
der anderen Seite weiter.
Also es zeigt so diese Ausrichtung der Ukraine, die früher überhaupt nicht nach
Westen war, weil von Kiew nach Charkiv hast du dann Autobahn und von Charkiv
nach Russland hast du Autobahn und von Kiew nach Odessa.
Also salopp gesagt, du kannst von Moskau nach Charkiv, Kiew und Odessa Autobahn fahren.
Also man merkt, das war offensichtlich so lange her bei Sowjetplanung.
Vor 50 bis 100 Jahren, Das war die Strecke, die gut gehen musste.
Und dann aber alles nach Westen wird immer, immer kleiner.
Und halt besonders dann dieser Übergang bei Krakowicz nach Polen,
wo du halt echt auf der einen Seite modernste Autobahnen so aus EU-Fördergeldern
hast, wo ich denke, top investiertes Geld, also wirklich gute Infrastruktur,
sinnvolles Investment.
Und auf der anderen Seite dann
diese eine Spur pro Fahrtrichtung ohne Standstreifen mit Schlaglöchern.
Und das ist einfach so optisch erkennbar dann, wie das vor Jahrzehnten geplant wurde.
Ja, weil ich ganz praktisch finde, es so Autoreisezüge gäbe.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob das irgendwie realistisch ist. Wahrscheinlich gibt
es das Material nicht mehr.
Ja und die Schienenbreite ist anders. Also die müssen ja an der Grenze tauschen.
Aber es gibt ja Nachtzüge, die von Warschau nach Kiew durchfahren,
weil da irgendwie die Schiene dann umgestellt wird oder die können die Achsen irgendwie ändern.
Aber wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, ist Warschau-Kiew mit dem Zug 15,
16 Stunden und der ist oft monatelang ausgebucht.
Also der ordentliche Nachtzug mit Betten, der bequem ist.
Und da muss man halt nach Warschau kommen, also hier mit dem Zug oder mit dem Flugzeug oder so.
Und wir hatten am Anfang von der vollen Invasion quasi alle Varianten durch,
von Auto in der Ukraine lassen und mit dem Zug hinfahren, nur Zug fahren,
fliegen bis nach Reschow und dann weiter.
Alles einmal durchgespielt.
Und am Ende ist für uns mit dem ganzen Equipment, was wir haben,
immer noch am praktischsten, wir fahren mit dem Auto durch, was unglaublich nervig ist.
Aber ist das Einzige, was sozusagen im Ablauf funktioniert. Und ein Autozug wäre unglaublich geil.
Oder auch, wenn man zumindest bis Lviv noch fliegen könnte und dann da das Auto
im Flughafenparkhaus oder so hätte.
Das würde das Leben alles so viel einfacher machen. Das Problem ist halt die Grenze.
Das fand ich auch spannend. Ich bin letztes Jahr, glaube ich,
in Kosovo gefahren mit dem Auto. Also weil ich so die Gegend da angucken wollte
und dann von da bis Odessa weiter.
Und ich kannte halt noch Grenzen mit dem Auto, als ich Kind war, ewig her,
und so quasi mein ganzes Leben, seitdem ich einen Führerschein habe,
war EU oder Flugreisen irgendwo hin, aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
dass ich mal bei eine internationale Nicht-EU-Grenze mit dem Auto gefahren wäre,
weil es einfach in meinem Leben nicht mehr vorkam.
Und dann diese ganzen, durch den Balkan war halt, du hast drei Autos vor dir
in einer Schlange, die im 30-Sekundentakt durchfahren, dann sagen die,
kann ich deinen Pass sehen? Ja, reicht, fahr weiter.
Ich dachte so, okay, das war's. Weil von Polen in die Ukraine ist halt,
jedes Auto wird durchsucht.
Alle Ausweise werden genau kontrolliert und das auf beiden Seiten.
Und von Einfahrtgrenze bis Ausfahrtgrenze braucht man so eine Stunde ungefähr
durch alle Kontrollen und so, bis man da durchgelaufen ist.
Aber die Schlange vor der Grenze ist meist zwischen einer und zehn Stunden.
Und wir haben dann versucht, morgens, mittags, abends fahren,
verschiedene Grenzübergänge und wir haben gemerkt, am Ende macht es keinen Unterschied.
Mal ist die Schlange lang und mal kurz. Also tendenziell ganz früh morgens ist
sie kürzer, weil es halt diese Ausgangssperre nachts in der Ukraine gibt,
im Grenzbereich meist bis 5 Uhr.
Das heißt, wenn man im letzten Dorf vor der Grenze pennt, in dem kleinsten Hotel,
was es gibt, und dann um 4.59 Uhr mit dem Zündschlüssel so im Auto sitzt und
5 Uhr losfährt und direkt zur Grenze, dann ist man meist relativ schnell durch.
Und alles andere scheint mir fast egal. Man weiß nie, wie lange es dauert.
Das ist halt auch so ein Punkt. Theoretisch könnte man Kiew,
Berlin in, ich glaube, 15 Stunden laut Google fahren, so oder 14.
Und das könnte man ja noch irgendwie halbwegs machen mit zwei Leuten.
Das wäre nervig, aber es geht.
Aber in der Praxis kommt das nicht hin, weil die Grenze dazwischen viel zu lang ist.
Und ich weiß, vor zwei Jahren bin ich mal Kiew-Hamburg gefahren am Stück,
weil Kongress war, 2023.
Weil wir haben Weihnachten Geschenke verteilt,
Hinter Kharkiv, aber ich wollte pünktlich beim Kongress sein.
Das alte Problem. Und dann bin ich tatsächlich alleine die Strecke durchgefahren.
Ja, genau, genau das. Ich glaube, ich bin 20 Stunden oder so gefahren.
Ich habe es geschafft, aber es war echt nicht lustig. Er sagt, nee, es lohnt nicht.
Ja, man kann nur hoffen, dass die Pläne, also es gibt natürlich Pläne für Fernstrecken,
also Neubau-Hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecken,
die dann eben auch mit dem westeuropäischen Schienenstandard sind.
Ich denke mal, wenn der Krieg vorbei ist, wird die Ukraine auch sehr schnell
anfangen, die alten Schienen rauszureißen.
Beziehungsweise, das geht natürlich nicht von heute auf morgen,
aber zumindest erstmal ein neues Streckennetz aufzubauen und schrittweise auf
die andere Spurbreite zu gehen. Allein um Russland da die Gelegenheit zu nehmen,
nochmal mit ihrer Spurbreite einzufallen, weil das wird Russland sowieso nicht los.
Ja, aber es ja.
Zumindest so Warschau-Lewive mit sowas wie einem also zumindest moderner IC
also jetzt nicht mal ICE-Geschwindigkeit sondern einfach, dass man schnell durchfährt
das wäre echt schon mal ein Ding,
damit wäre eine Menge gewonnen und auch mit dem Zug ich bin auch mal Zug gefahren
da dauert die Grenze genauso lang da steht man so ein, zwei Stunden bis alles
kontrolliert ist, der Vorteil ist halt nur du hast so ein Schlafabteil und kannst
halt pennen oder liegen bleiben.
Mit dem Auto an der Grenze ist es halt alle fünf Minuten, drei Meter vor und
man muss immer irgendwie aufpassen sozusagen.
Zug ist schon, ich würde sagen, von allen Varianten, die ich so kenne,
das bequemste. Also es ist angenehm und es klappt, aber es ist schwieriger.
So, ich denke, jetzt haben wir deine Reise ganz gut abgedeckt.
Was man auf jeden Fall aber noch erwähnen sollte ist, du hast ja nebenbei immer
wieder fallen lassen, wissen wir auch,
du betreibst ja ein Museum in einem ehemaligen Bunker hier in Berlin.
Und ja, letztes Mal, als ich dich überraschend besuchen kam, habe ich festgestellt,
nicht nur gibt es die jetzt schon seit Jahren immer wieder gut besuchte Hitler-Ausstellung,
sondern du hast jetzt auch noch einen weiteren Bereich des Bunkers ertüchtigt
und dort eine Ausstellung zu dem Krieg von Russland gegen die Ukraine gemacht.
Genau, wir hatten am Anfang, also quasi seit Beginn der Invasion,
einen ganz kleinen Raum, den wir noch über hatten, wo es uns irgendwie ein Anliegen
war, irgendwas zur Ukraine zu machen. Das wurde der Sache nicht gerecht.
Jetzt haben wir so 300 Quadratmeter ungefähr. Man muss sagen,
vor war es auch mehr wie so ein Sammelsorium oder so, was wir erlebten.
Also so das Pendant zu einem Tweet oder so, mit wenig Kontext, wenn man mal so will.
Aber halt nichts, was ein Mensch, der die Sache nicht kennt,
versteht. Also was ja eigentlich der Anspruch von einer Ausstellung ist.
Und jetzt ist es halt so, dass es wirklich eine Erzählung ist von der Krieg
geht los, was heißt das, bleibt man, geht man, wenn man im Land ist,
wenn man nicht im Land ist, solidarisiert man sich oder stellt man sich dagegen
oder sagt, hier stellt euch nicht so an.
Viele Sachen, die wir aus der Ukraine mitbringen, sind eben technisch.
Also so man sagt, da kann man was dran erklären, aber es ist eher was für Technikmuseum.
Dann eben so ein bisschen schwierig, den Bogen zu machen von,
was heißt diese Technik für normalen Menschen?
Also was ist eine FPW-Drohne? Warum interessiert mich so ein ferngesteuertes Flugzeug sinngemäß?
Deswegen haben wir jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr so drüber nachgedacht und immer
versucht, was heißt das für normale Menschen da draußen.
Da ist auch wieder ganz gut, also wie viel man dann inzwischen bei der Planung mit Social Media macht.
Zum Beispiel hatte ich vor einer Weile gefragt, wenn ich euch erklären müsste,
wie groß eine Bombe ist oder eine Rakete, welche Maßeinheit würdet ihr verstehen?
Weil wie viel Kilo Sprengstoff oder so versteht, ja normaler Mensch nicht,
aber ich bin zu betriebsblind, um zu überlegen, was heißt das.
Und die allermeisten haben gesagt, wie groß ist das Loch, also was die macht,
wie sieht das nachher aus.
Sagt, okay, gut, dann also genau solche Sachen dann mal nehmen und nicht nur
sagen, das ist eine riesen Rakete, sondern und hier hast du ein Bild,
was die für einen Schaden anrichtet und was heißt das jetzt und ja, so,
haben wir uns da durchgearbeitet und das Ding ist jetzt, ich würde sagen 80,
90 Prozent fertig, wir haben ja immer noch ein Schild vorne stehen,
dass es wie so ein Sneak Preview ist.
Ein Hauptelement, was noch fehlt, weil sich der Export zieht,
Im April diesen Jahres ist ein Freund von uns von einer Partnerorganisation
in Rehason von einer FPW-Drohne getötet worden.
Also der Typ aus Rehason, der da immer gewohnt hat, der auch während der Besatzung
durch Russland da geblieben ist, also absichtlich geblieben ist,
weil er gesagt hat, das ist meine Stadt.
Und der da weiter versucht hat, gegen die Russen zu arbeiten und der dann auch
in Gefangenschaft geraten ist, der aber nachher immer noch in der Stadt war
und der sowas wie ein Sozialtaxi betrieben hat,
also alte Leute zum Arzt fahren oder Evakuierung aus den umliegenden Gegenden machen.
Und bei einer von den Fahrten sind sie halt von einer Drohne erwischt worden,
waren zwei Leute im Auto, der eine ist getötet worden und der andere hat es überlebt.
Und wir haben das Auto dort rausbekommen, was halt ungefähr ein Meter großes
Loch im Dach hat und drinnen auch kaputt ist.
Und das bringen wir jetzt in die Ausstellung, um genau das Leuten zu zeigen.
So, was heißt das in der Praxis?
Und auch in diesem Fall, wir kennen die Leute da drin.
Nur um den Deppen vorzugreifen, das war 100% kein Militär. Also so kann ich
in dem Fall ganz sicher sagen.
Wir haben vom ukrainischen Nachrichtendienst das Video bekommen aus der russischen
Drohne von dem Anflug, weil das hatten sie abgefangen und wir haben gefragt,
ob sie uns das für den Zweck geben können und gesagt, ja klar,
wir haben das Video aus dem Wagen wie sie getroffen wurden und wir haben die
Aussagen von dem, der überlebt hat in dem Video, also wir haben die gesamte
Geschichte und wir haben das Fahrzeug und haben gesagt, das ist halt so ein
Punkt wo man dann eine Geschichte,
so klar und anfassbar macht, wo es um zivile Opfer geht, um Leute,
die einfach nur geholfen haben.
Den Wagen hierher zu bekommen, war überraschend kompliziert,
weil der einer NGO gehörte und steuerfrei importiert wurde.
Und es in der Ukraine immer wieder Fälle gab, dass so Autos dann verschwunden
sind oder dass so Fake-NGOs versucht haben, so ein Bentley als NGO-Auto steuerfrei
zu importieren oder so ein Scheiß. Also alles mögliche gab es.
Das heißt, sie sind jetzt sehr vorsichtig, was ja gut ist. Das heißt nur,
eigentlich dürfen die Autos nicht verkauft oder exportiert werden.
Also braucht man eine Art Ausnahme, dass wir das dürfen und es zieht sich.
Jetzt ist der letzte Punkt, dass der Zoll das Auto selber sehen will,
weil die sagen, wir glauben euch das alles, aber mit all diesen Vorwürfen mit
Betrug und Vetternwirtschaft, wir wollen 100 pro sicher sein. Ja, alles gut.
Nur deswegen zog sich das jetzt
über Wochen, ein vermeintlich einfacher Punkt, das Auto rüber zu holen.
Jetzt sind wir aber kurz davor, dass wir es endlich hier haben und dann in die
Ausstellung packen können.
Wo ist das Auto jetzt?
Quasi an der polnisch-ukrainischen Grenze auf der ukrainischen Seite noch.
Also wir haben es erst vom, auch ist auch so irre, wer dann hilft.
Wir haben den Ukrainern gesagt, dass wir halt das Auto aus dem absoluten Gefahrenbereich
aus Sichtweite der russischen Armee rausholen wollen.
Und die ukrainische Armee hat uns geholfen, das Auto zu bergen.
Also weil die gesagt haben, für den Zweck, verstehen wir aber, macht das nicht selber.
Und dann stand es jetzt, also da mussten wir es irgendwo zwischenparken,
sozusagen in einem sicheren Bereich, wo es einen Autotransporter abholen kann.
Und was ist sicher? Ein ehemaliges Atombombensilo. Also da, wo wir vor zwei
Jahren die Atombomben ankurken waren.
Auf dem Gelände hat es Militär gesagt, ihr könnt den hier parken,
weil das Gelände ist ja riesig, also es ist ja heute ein Museum.
Aber dann ist es sozusagen an einem Ort, der immer erreichbar ist und wo man
es abholen kann und der sicher ist.
Ja, der einen Zaun drumherum hat und so weiter.
Genau, und das fand ich auch irre, wie nett die dann helfen bei sowas und sagen,
es ist doch für uns keine Arbeit.
Hast du das vorgeschlagen?
Nee, die haben das vorgeschlagen. Das war Zufall. Genau, also die haben gesagt,
sie holen das ja eh raus und sagten, ihr könnt das auch hier zwischenparken,
wenn das hilft. Ich sagte, ja, das hilft sehr.
Und jetzt geht es halt an die Grenze zur Beschau und so weiter.
Und dann geht es mit so einem ganz normalen Autotransporter.
Die fahren ja oft leer aus der Ukraine raus und voll rein zur Zeit.
Und einer davon nimmt es dann mit. Und man sagt, es reicht, es muss nur in der EU sein.
Dann können wir es mit so einem ADAC-Transporter ja abholen lassen,
weil es ist halt von der Größe her ein normaler Wagen.
Oder wenn ihr es durchbringen könnt, besser, ja.
Aber damit geht es ja nicht los. Ich war ja schon da. Ja, also ihr habt das
im Prinzip schon weitgehend fertig.
Ja, genau. Der größte Teil ist da.
Es sind auch schon Leute immer mal wieder da oder werden durchgeführt.
Aber es wird dann auch irgendwann eine offizielle Eröffnung geben, oder?
Genau, am 24.02. war dann die Idee, weil wir brauchen noch ein bisschen,
um fertig zu machen die letzten Sachen.
Aber dann zu vier Jahren Kriegsbeginn sozusagen.
Genau, zu einem Jahr hatten wir den Panzer gebracht. Die letzten Jahre haben
wir halt nichts gemacht, weil ich denke immer, wenn man keine schlaue Idee hat,
dann muss man nicht irgendwie sich versuchen, was auszudenken, was keinen Sinn ergibt.
Das ist dann zu vier Jahren die Eröffnung davon, ja.
Aber falls irgendjemand Lust hat, sich jetzt anzuschauen, kann man vorbeikommen.
Genau.
Ja, cool. Ich glaube, dabei lassen wir es jetzt erstmal. War auf jeden Fall ein sinnvolles Update.
Wenn sich wieder die Gelegenheit ergibt, werde ich ja auch mit Pawel dann nochmal
in andere Details reingehen.
Aber ich denke, das reicht jetzt erstmal im Wesentlichen.
Steuern wir auf dieses unrühmliche Datum des vierjährigen Kriegsbeginns ein.
Wobei, man muss immer wieder betonen, der Krieg läuft schon viel,
viel länger und nur diese Full-Scale-Invasion, wie alle immer so schön sagen, die...
Die ist jetzt dann auch schon vier Jahre her und ich finde, es ist ein Armutszeugnis
für Europa und den Westen, dass das nicht in den Griff bekommen wird.
Denn ich denke, alle, die sich so ein bisschen näher damit beschäftigen,
stellen immer wieder fest, es wäre möglich gewesen, diesen Krieg zu beenden.
Und früh, also wenn man früh stark reingegangen wäre.
Genau, man hat Russland viel zu viel Zeit gelassen,
seine Kräfte da zu mobilisieren, denn Russland hat sich definitiv verschätzt
und das Ganze läuft jetzt eigentlich nur noch,
weil der Starkopf Putin sich quasi eine Niederlage nicht leisten kann,
denn das wäre dann auch mit Sicherheit das Ende seiner Regentschaft.
Und die sollte man anstreben, weil das wird nicht besser da in Russland.
Es ist ein bisschen so wie mit Deutschland im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Man muss einfach so lange Feste draufhauen, bis der Spuk vorbei ist.
Und derzeit gibt es einfach nicht genug Einigkeit, um hier einfach mal die Sache zu Ende zu bringen.
Naja gut, aber wir bleiben auf jeden Fall am Thema dran.
Ja, danke Enno und danke fürs Zuhören hier bei UKW. bald geht es wieder weiter.
Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.